Oh, Leute, der Chat geht nicht, oder?
Ah, doch, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt funktioniert er.
Exzellent.
Schon so viele Leute, so früh am Start hier.
Wir sind 20 Minuten oder 30 Minuten fast schon früher als sonst.
Poggers.
Oreki, 91, zwei Monate, massive Big Brain Subscription hier.
Subscription-Scam.
Gleich, wenn es so weitergeht, kommt auch gleich noch der Scam-Train
und she baited alle zu weiter-subscriben.
Ich habe übrigens...
Wann das? Freitag?
Ich habe am Freitag mit Hetzner telefoniert, wegen Sponsor-Stells.
Das heißt, da gibt es demnächst wahrscheinlich was, ja.
Wir müssen uns noch einig werden, was wir da genau machen.
Zum Beispiel, ich bin jetzt nur drauf gekommen, weil ich gerade den Nightbot gesehen habe.
Zum Beispiel haben wir uns überlegt, man könnte den Nightbot einfach
so einen Gutschein-Link alle, keine Ahnung, Viertelstunde mal posten lassen.
Und ich sage...
Ich sage auch ab und zu mal was zu irgendwas in der Richtung.
Ich weiß so nicht genau.
Muss man mal gucken.
Nee, nee, das darf der Nightbot schon mitmachen.
Man könnte ihn auch umbenennen.
Erholsamer nachgehaben.
Nee, ehrlich gesagt nicht.
Wisst ihr warum?
Oder vielleicht kann er...
Vielleicht ist ja sogar der Steffberto dran schuld.
Ich weiß ja nicht.
Ich glaube, irgendjemand hat mein Android-Tablet gehacksort.
Naja, okay, um ehrlich zu sein, ich glaube nicht, dass es jemand gehacksort hat.
Ich glaube, mein Android-Tablet ist einfach kaputt.
Ich habe mich schon die letzten, die letzten, keine Ahnung, zwei Wochen oder so gefragt,
warum nachts, warum es nachts bei mir im Schlafzimmer ab und zu piepst.
So unregelmäßig.
Einmal die Nacht, zwei, dreimal die Nacht.
Und ich habe die Klimaanlage ausgemacht.
Ich habe die Uhr, den Wecker ausgemacht.
Ich habe...
Ich habe die Fernbedienung, Batterien entfernt.
Und die Fernbedienung, Batterien für die Klimaanlage entfernt.
Ich habe alles ausgemacht.
Und irgendwie hat es trotzdem weiter gepiept.
Und heute Morgen hatte ich das Tablet in der Hand.
Und da hat das Tablet gepiept.
Und da habe ich dann mal gegoogelt.
Und es gibt wohl irgendeinen Bug bei Android-Tablets, dass die manchmal piepen.
Normalerweise sollen sie das nur machen, wenn irgendwie der Akku kaputt ist oder so.
Nee, nee, Feuermelde.
Da habe ich auch schon überprüft, ob Batterie leer geht.
Aber dafür war es nicht laut genug und auch nicht Feuer...
Man weiß nicht, ja.
Kann ja auch sein.
Nee, aber ganz, ganz komisch.
Und dann habe ich mal Google-Stells gemacht.
Da habe ich so hier Android-Bieb.
So.
Äh.
Random.
Irgendwie.
So, da habe ich ein Google-Video gefunden.
Wo irgendein Typ sein, sein, sein Handy gezeigt hat.
Android-Phone keeps beeping.
Ich weiß nicht, ich habe, ich habe...
Das da?
Hier, genau.
Hier, guck mal.
Und genau das Gepiepe hat mein Handy auch, hat mein Tablet auch gemacht.
Nur nicht so oft.
Das hat genau den gleichen Bieb gemacht.
Nur, keine Ahnung, random.
Alle paar Stunden mal.
Stellt euch mal vor.
Wenn ihr nachkommt.
Macht es keine Ahnung haben.
Das macht random einfach.
Dann, dann monkaerst ihr schon ein bisschen, ja.
Und guckt, wo kommt das her.
Und da habe ich mal geguckt.
Amazon-Tablets sind anscheinend bekannter für so Dinger zu machen.
Äh, wenn man nämlich hier nachguckt.
Es kommt relativ häufig vor.
Ups.
Was haben wir jetzt gemacht?
So.
Äh, es kommt relativ häufig vor.
Das ist, ich meine hier, das ist ja nicht komplett nicht von ungefähr.
Dass es so viele Einträge gibt.
Und die schreiben halt, es liegt daran, dass entweder der Akku kaputt geht oder dass irgendwelche Notification-Sounds nicht gemutet sind.
Also ich habe alles geguckt, ich habe nichts gefunden.
Habe ich jetzt gemacht, habe ich einfach auf das Tablet ausgeschaltet.
Ja.
Das Chinesenbotnet.
Das China-Chinesenbotnet.
Vielleicht, vielleicht.
Und wenn man halt sagen muss, ich benutze dort drauf eigentlich nur Browser mit eingebautem Adblocker, entgooglelifiziert und alles.
Das ist ja nicht ganz möglich, also ich glaube so den, so den großen Angriffsvektor hat mein Tablet nicht.
Ähm.
Gut, aber ich meine im Endeffekt, es suckt eh, das Fire-Tablet.
Also ich habe ja so, ich habe jetzt das ganz billige mal gekauft für 50 Euro.
So eins, äh, mal sieben ist das billige, ne?
Okay, dann habe ich ein Achter gekauft.
Man muss immer warten, bis es die Hälfte kostet, für 50 Euro irgendwie reduziert so.
Und das ist halt, das ist halt schon ein ziemliches Crap-Tablet.
Ich meine, das ist preis-leistungsmäßig das beste Android-Tablet, was es gibt.
Aber, es ist halt, es ist halt im Vergleich zu anderen Tablets Müll.
Dazu kommt, dass es relativ wenige gescheite Android-Tablets gibt.
Piepen für den Akku kaputt wäre richtig bescheuert.
Weiß ich nicht, ich weiß bloß nicht, was die Leute in einem Forum geschrieben haben.
Guck hier.
So nach dem Motto, Batterie ist fast leer, ich piep's nochmal, dass die Batterie schneller leer geht.
Also man findet total viel zu Amazon Fire.
Und, und Fire-Tablet und so piepst und sowas.
So, und was ich jetzt mache ist, ich kaufe mir einfach ein iPad.
Ich bin ja, wie gesagt, was Tablets angeht, kein großartiger Android-Fan.
Ich meine, ich habe genug ausprobiert.
Ich habe mittlerweile an die elf Android-Tablets am Start.
Und irgendwie gefällt mir keins davon richtig gut.
Gut, das waren jetzt auch, da waren jetzt bis auf eins auch keine höherpreisigen Geräte dabei.
Das war, ähm, das eine war beispielsweise...
...ein Werbegeschenk damals.
Dann sind es zwei Shield-Tablets, die eigentlich ganz gut sind.
Aber die Shield-Tablets haben komplett ihre Akkupower schon verloren, die sind zu alt.
Dann sind es zwei Fire HD10, die funktionieren tatsächlich gut als Dashboards für meine Heimautomatisierung.
Ähm, dann habe ich so ein altes Tegra-Note, das sagt, das ist schon komplett, komplett, äh, kannst schon komplett knicken.
Dann ein Asus, dann habe ich mir einmal gedacht, ich kaufe mir ein halbwegs gescheites Android-Tablet.
Habe ich mir vor, vor drei, vier Jahren gekauft.
Und dann hat Asus gesagt, ach nee, jebaited, wir stellen einfach einen Monat, nachdem du es gekauft hast, den Support ein.
So, und dann habe ich mir gedacht, okay, ich habe jetzt so viele Tablets da am Start gehabt, kein Problem.
Und ich habe hier für meine Mutter schon vor drei Jahren oder so ein iPad gekauft.
Ich glaube, das ist noch ein iPhone, iPad 5 oder so.
Was gibt es da, Generations?
Was gibt es für iPad Generations? Zeigt mal her.
Ich glaube, das ist zu neu.
Das ist zu neu?
Ich vermute mal das hier.
Aber es bekommt noch, es bekommt noch Updates, das weiß ich.
Ja gut, dann muss es das hier sein, weil das ist, ja, ja, 5th Generation iPad.
Das bekommt nämlich noch, das bekommt nämlich noch, äh, Updates.
Das heißt, äh, das müsste, das müsste das sein.
So, zumindest habe ich ja das gekauft vor, vor hier wahrscheinlich drei Jahren oder so.
Oder so dreieinhalb Jahren.
Und ich muss echt sagen, ich benutze das auch manchmal.
Ich finde das vollkommen in Ordnung, ja.
Also besser als alle Android-Tablets, die ich bisher hatte.
Bei Smartphones kann man sich vielleicht noch drum streiten, aber ganz ehrlich, so im Tablet-Bereich hat mich nichts überzeugt.
Das iPad ist das Beste.
Es hat natürlich auch ein paar Nachteile.
Wie gesagt, es hat alles irgendwo seine Vor- und Nachteile.
Beispielsweise hat, äh, iPad halt so diese typischen Apple-Geschichten, so nach dem Motto, du musst das halt unseren Weg machen oder gar nicht.
Zum Beispiel, was du halt bei Apple nicht machen kannst, ist, dass du, ähm, automatisch Notifications öffnest und sowas.
Das ist natürlich normalerweise auch sinnvoll, keine Notifications zu öffnen, ja.
Also für den normalen 0815-Benutzer ist das schon sinnvoll.
Du willst ja nicht, dass irgendeine Website Notifications macht oder irgendeine App amok läuft, Notifications macht, automatisch Dinger öffnet, Links öffnet, sonst was.
Klar, das willst du nicht.
Aber zum Beispiel, wo man das will, ist, wenn man eine App hat von seiner Kamera am Hoftor.
Und will zum Beispiel das machen.
Und will zum Beispiel, dass es nach einem Klick oder am besten gar keinem Klick automatisch aufgeht.
Das ist was, das kannst du unter Android halt easy machen.
Mit Tasker oder irgendwelchem anderen Scripting-Zeug.
Es ist hoffnungslos, außer du hast vielleicht ein gejailbreaktes iPad eventuell, äh, das mit einem iOS zu machen.
Geht halt einfach nicht.
So.
Übrigens, haben die nicht demnächst hier Apple Spring Event?
Spring Loaded, genau.
What to a- The Verge.
Warte mal.
Die, die das mit diesem tollen, mit dieser tollen Anleitung zum PC bauen, die haben ja Ahnung, ja.
Am 20.04. ist quasi wie die Ubuntu-Version.
Am 20.04. ist das Apple Event.
Okay, das Apple Event ist genau am gleichen Datum, wie der Name der aktuellen Ubuntu LTS-Version.
Ich vermute da irgendwelche Verschwörungstheorien.
So, was vermuten sie denn?
iPad Pro.
Warte mal, ich muss mal kurz.
Leute, Achtung, Flashbang.
Flashbang, die Seite klappt mit Darkreadern.
Wobei, ich, es ist früh, ich, ich Flashbang euch nicht.
Aber vielleicht gibt's ne bessere Seite, hier irgendwas als The Verge.
Okay, die Seite kann man gar nicht Darkreadern.
Äh, doch.
Die sieht sogar Darkreadert relativ gut aus.
Also, was iPad Pro.
Die, die, die Dinger sind halt viel zu teuer.
Das seh ich, das seh ich nicht ein.
Was ist eigentlich der Unterschied zwischen nem Air und nem normalen iPad, außer dass es das Doppelte kostet?
Und wahrscheinlich ein bisschen leichter ist.
Aber nicht, dass mich das Gewicht großartig schocken würde von nem iPad.
So, okay.
Apple, die Apple-Seite funktioniert nicht mit, mit dem Hintergrund.
Oh, guck mal, Apple ist ultra lazy beim Webdesign.
Das ist einfach nen Bild.
Das ist einfach nen Bild mit der gleichen Hintergrundfarbe.
Das ist noch nicht mal transparentes Bild.
Keck, wait, Apple.
Keck, wait.
Ähm, das ist noch nicht mal ein transparentes Bild.
Das ist einfach ein Bild mit der Hintergrundfarbe.
Das ist ein Bild mit der Hintergrundfarbe von der Webseite.
Das ist ja billig, Apple.
Da hätt ich, da hätt ich jetzt von Apple mehr erwartet.
So, ähm.
Der, der Scheiß ist halt ultra teuer, ne?
Die iPad Pros.
Mal guckst, dass er unterstützt die zweite Generation Apple Pencils.
Okay, das brauch ich nicht.
Das juckt mich nicht.
So, also ich will auf jeden Fall nen 11-Zoll-Display.
Ganz ehrlich, mir wär sogar noch ein kleineres Display lieber.
Ich benutze das nur abends im Bett, um noch ein bisschen YouTube und Streams zu gucken.
Und zwischendurch mal drauf zu schauen.
Äh, was hat denn das iPad?
Also ich vermute mal, dass meine Mutter das iPad das fünfte oder sechste Generation hat.
Ähm, was haben die, was haben die für ne Größe?
Was haben die für ne Displaygröße?
9,7?
9,7, okay.
Jetzt hat er auf jeden Fall 9,7.
Ja.
Das ist mir eigentlich schon fast nen Ticken zu groß gewesen.
Wenn ich da im Bett zum Streams gucken.
Aber es gibt halt nix kleineres als 11 in dem Fall.
Was natürlich cool ist, haben die, haben die Face-ID?
Warte mal, man kann auch irgendwie vergleichen.
iPad vergleichen.
Moment, ich muss mal gucken, was hat denn Face-ID?
Face-ID finde ich ist nämlich ne coole, ne coole Geschichte.
Woop, Leak.
Okay, okay, was kann man vergleichen?
iPad Pro.
Moment, warum ist das vierte Generation und das ist zweite, vierte...
Hä?
Apple.
Was?
Das ist doch im Prinzip genau das gleiche, nur mit kleinerem, kleinerem Display, oder?
Phone KS, Alter.
Kriegt doch keiner durch.
Okay.
Face, was hat Face-ID?
Ah, das hat Face...
Ne, nicht Face-ID, ne Moment, das ist FaceTime.
Das hat Face-ID.
Aha, nur die Pros haben Face-ID.
Hm.
Mein Face-ID ist schon nice, ja.
Ich hab das auch nie verwendet, weil ich immer gesagt hab, ah, Alter, Passwort, beste.
Bei einem iPhone ist Face-ID tatsächlich ganz nice.
Das ist ja überhaupt ein Unterschied dazwischen, zwischen den zwei.
Das ist genau das gleiche.
Hahaha.
Apple.
Ganz bestimmt, ganz bestimmt.
Für einen Terabyte muss ich dann erstmal 800 Euro plus bezahlen, oder so.
Ne, ja, ja, ja, Apple, ganz sicher, ganz sicher.
Moment.
Warum kostet das... Achso, das ist das...
Ich hab's verkehrt rum sortiert.
Das ist doch genau das gleiche.
Warum ist das eine zweite Generation
und das andere vierte Generation?
Ach, vielleicht ist das zweite Generation
vom 11 Zoll iPad Pro.
Okay, die Benahmung ist aber beknackt.
Normalerweise nimmst du ja die Hardware Generation
und dann, wenn das Display unterschiedlich groß ist, meinetwegen.
Aber, trotzdem.
Okay, Apples.
Na gut, Apple macht das schon gut.
Apple macht das schon gut, weil die Leute denken sich,
ach, komm, für, für, für,
keine Ahnung, für...
Ach, komm, für 200 Euro,
für 150 Euro mehr krieg ich quasi schon
vierte Generation.
Das ist eigentlich richtig Sixthead.
Was machst du gerade? Ich guck gerade, ob ich mir ein neues iPad kaufe.
Dann gucken wir uns ein paar Videos an.
iPad Air 2020,
Real iPad Pro Killer.
Na gut, aber iPad Air hat kein Face ID.
Face ID fänd ich schon ziemlich cool.
Schreib mal das Face ID.
Also, ganz ehrlich,
Face ID wär das einzige,
warum ich mir ein iPad kaufen würde,
was kein normales
iPad für 379 Euro ist.
Wobei, mal ganz im Ernst,
ich seh's nicht ein, für Face ID
das Doppelte zu bezahlen.
Das ist halt echt lol.
Ansonsten, was,
mal ganz im Ernst, was ist der Unterschied?
Gibt doch eigentlich
keinen großartigen, ja.
Das hier ist mir sogar lieber.
Zehn Monate lang
schön exquisite Subscription hier.
Also, guck mal.
Also das ist mir sogar lieber von der Größe.
Kann man mal bitte
jemand die Katze über uns...
Ne, warum?
Die muss da bleiben.
Die sitzt ja noch nicht mal im Weg.
Die ist...
Die beobachtet den Chat.
Dass der Chat keinen Scheiß baut.
Gut, also
wahrscheinlich ist
die Abmaße ungefähr gleich,
ja, geh ich auch mal von aus.
Aber das stört mich nicht.
Zoll reicht mir auch, dicke.
So, das macht wahrscheinlich
absolut keinen Unterschied
in dem, was man täglich damit macht.
Ob das jetzt ein A12Z oder ein A12 ist.
Und das hier ist ein A14.
Warum hat das Pro denn bitteschön
einen älteren Prozessor als das andere?
Okay, wahrscheinlich
weil das...
Okay, blick ich nicht durch.
Das ist alles in Ordnung, reicht mir dicke.
Ich nehm eh die 32G Variante, wozu braucht man mehr?
Die wissen schon genau, warum die
eine MicroSD-Karte da drin einbauen.
Reicht mir auch, dicke.
Ob es ein Lightning-Anschluss oder nicht
ist, juckt mich persönlich jetzt nicht großartig.
USB-C wär mir lieber, aber ich hab
genug von allem.
Ja, es gibt ja die Vermutung, dass die ein neues iPad Pro
hier vorstellen. Schreiben sie ja auch hier.
Neues iPad Pro.
Aber das ist erstmal wahrscheinlich
schwer zu bekommen und es kostet zu viel.
Also ganz ehrlich,
ich seh keinen Vorteil
für mich, das da fürs
Doppelte zu kaufen, anstatt das da
zu kaufen.
Ich mein, es kostet einfach das Doppelte.
Also außer wenn man
Stift-Stells machen will,
ist das doch eigentlich gar nicht wert.
Das juckt mich halt auch nicht.
Wahrscheinlich
kauf ich mir einfach das da.
Ich wart mal das Apple-Event ab, weil vielleicht werden
die Dinger irgendwie billiger nach dem Apple-Event.
Wobei, keck, wait.
Jetzt hab ich mich selbst gebetet, als würde
das irgendwie billiger werden.
Da gibt's höchstens ne neue Version, die dann irgendwie nochmal
100€ mehr kostet.
Ja, mal gucken.
Ich glaub auch, dass die
eher teurer werden.
So, was stellen sie denn noch vor?
iPad Pro wird vermutet da so vorstellen, ok.
Apple Pencil 3
juckt mich jetzt persönlich gar nicht.
Achso, was ist denn da jetzt der Unterschied
zwischen iPad Mini 5. Generation?
Das, ok.
Das ist eigentlich ne schöne Größe.
Die gefällt mir ehrlich gesagt.
Warum ist das eigentlich kleiner und teurer,
obwohl die gleiche Hardware drin ist?
Also, mehr oder weniger.
Strongs.
Also, wirklich,
wirklich, äh,
wirklich erkennen tut man das
nicht, warum das, ne?
Aber Apple-Logik halt.
iPad Mini ist
jetzt so klein. Ich find das gerade gut,
ganz ehrlich. Ich find sogar,
ich fand das alte, dieses
9,7 Zoll, was ich meiner Mutter gekauft hab,
sogar schon zu groß.
Also, das ist eigentlich, für mich ist das hier
richtig schneise Größe.
Aber wahrscheinlich kauf ich das.
Wahrscheinlich kauf ich wieder ganz normal, dass 379 Euro gut ist.
Übrigens, man wird übelst
gebetet, wenn man sich, äh, übelst
gebetet, wenn man sich ein iPad kauft, ne?
Ich hab damals auch den Fehler gemacht.
Also, wenn man hier war, was weiß ich, bla bla bla.
So, und hier,
und hier kommt der Gebet.
Das ist eigentlich Big Brain von Apple.
Massive Gebet. Wenn du sagst,
keine Gravur, ist alles ok.
Aber wenn du sagst, hups,
wenn du sagst,
Gravur, also hier,
Keg W,
Keg Weight,
so, und sobald du, sobald du Gravur
hast, kannst du es nicht mal zurückgeben,
weil es für dich personalisiert ist.
Ist eigentlich, eigentlich
Massive Brain von Apple, das kostenlos anzubieten.
Die Leute denken sich, oh cool,
kostenlose Gravur, lul.
Tja.
She baited.
Da ist nix mehr mit zurückgeben,
wenn das graviert, gravierend
wirren lassen hast.
Eigentlich, eigentlich
richtig clever von Apple, das zu machen.
Tipp für ein günstiges Tablet für meine Eltern.
Ja, ein iPad, das da.
Schlag dich da, also gerade für die Eltern,
auch, selbst wenn die nicht so technikbasiert sind,
es gibt eigentlich kein vergleichbares
Android Tablet, was
preismäßig und, und
komfortmäßig für die etwas ältere
Generation so gut funktioniert.
Bei Smartphones
kann man sich drum streiten, aber ich finde gerade,
wenn man ein Tablet für die Eltern kauft, ist das iPad
das Beste, was du machen kannst.
Es sei denn, du hast irgendwelche Anwendungszwecke,
die halt nicht gehen mit einem iPad,
dann, dann könntest
du ein Android kaufen. Aber ansonsten, ganz ehrlich,
würde ich das kaufen.
379 ist auch echt preis-leistungsmäßig ganz gut.
Hätte ich gar nicht mal gedacht, dass Apple das Ding am Start hat,
was preis-leistungsmäßig mir auch am besten
gefällt. Alles Matze,
nee, das hast du nicht, wenn du das
bestellst, wenn du das markierst und
bestellst das, ich versuch das
jetzt mal, ob man das irgendwie,
ah nee, ich muss erstmal bezahlen,
die sagen dir dann auch beim Bestellvorgang,
wenn das custom für dich graviert
wird, musst du zustimmen,
dass es quasi so eine Art Maßanfertigung
für dich ist und
du deswegen darauf verzichtest,
auf dein, auf dein
Rückgaberecht.
Steht hier natürlich alles nicht dabei,
ja, kann man mal gucken.
iPad Gravur Rückgabe.
Okay, great.
Tja, siehste?
Das schreiben die auch.
Das schreiben die auch, wenn du bestellst.
Jaja, man muss, man muss zustimmen,
also das kann man Apple da in dem
Fall gar nicht vorwerfen. Ganz ehrlich,
ich verstehe das auch, dass
man keine gravierten Geräte zurücknehmen
will, aber, dass
die diese kostenlose Gravur anbieten, liegt
meiner Meinung nach eindeutig daran,
dass man das eben nicht mehr zurückgeben
kann. Ne, das ist, ich verstehe
es auf der einen Seite, dass man es nicht zurücknimmt,
aber auf der anderen Seite ist es halt meiner Meinung nach
eindeutig ein Five-Hat-Trick-Move,
dass man es nicht
zurück, 32G reicht, jaja.
Also, ich weiß
nicht, ob es euch reicht, aber ich bin
noch nie, im Chat, mal fragen
euch, seid ihr irgendwie mal an die, an die
Größengrenzen von eurem Tablet
gestoßen? Ich nehme immer nur das kleinste,
also in dem Fall 32G,
das reicht dicke.
Ich habe da überhaupt gar keine Probleme,
zumal, wenn man da,
ich speichere da sogar die ein oder anderen
Videos, Fotos und sonstige
Sachen drauf, selbst wenn man das macht
und es wird zu voll,
dann ist der größte Teil des
Speichers immer noch Videos, beziehungsweise
Fotos und die kann man auch woanders
haben, die muss man ja nicht permanent auf dem Tablet
oder auf dem Smartphone
mit sich rumtragen. Aber selbst da, man
kommt eigentlich nicht an die Grenze.
Ich weiß nicht, ob einer von euch schon mal geschafft hat,
sein Tablet voll zu machen.
Ne.
Also, ja gut, es gibt
immer Low-Brain-Leute, ja.
Man muss ja nicht in der Cloud speichern, man kann es
auch bei sich auf dem File-Server oder sonst wo speichern.
Das ist überhaupt kein Problem.
Okay, 16G ist vielleicht echt ein bisschen klein, das stimmt.
Aber selbst
16G wird wahrscheinlich auskommen.
Der Sbarro ist da.
Und Sbarro
ist das,
ist das Glückshormon-Level immer noch
oben. Stonks.
Ja gut, wenn man, wenn man
viel Musik speichern will auf dem
Gerät, dann verstehe ich das.
Aber muss ich halt überlegen,
es ist halt
verdammt teuer, Speicher, ne.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Also, Speicher
ist halt viel zu teuer.
Selbst beim normalen iPad.
So, kaufen.
Guck mal, die wollen allen
Ernstes,
die wollen allen Ernstes
von 32,
kann man das, das kann man nicht besser,
die wollen allen Ernstes von 32G auf 180,
100 Euro mehr. Wisst ihr, was das kostet?
Das kostet nix.
Normalerweise nix.
Das ist, das ist
paar Euro, was das kostet.
Ich mein, die machen das ja schon
clever, ne. Die machen das insofern
schon clever, die schreiben 32G
und schreiben hier 128G hin, weil da sagen
die Leute im Kopf,
das ist ja viermal mehr,
das ist natürlich gerechtfertigt,
dass das 100 Euro ist.
Ist es aber nicht.
Der Scheiß ist viel,
ist teuer. 100 Euro.
Guck mal, ihr kriegt für den Preis,
ihr kriegt für 100 Euro, komm, wir gucken mal, was es
für eine SSD gibt mit 100 Euro.
Auf 500G, 500G SSD.
So,
guck mal.
Eine 500G SSD, 500G
SSD, kostet nur
57 Euro.
So, also, wir können sogar, du kannst dir
eine Terabyte, Terabyte SSD
kaufen,
quasi für den Preis
sogar günstiger, als wo die Apple
100G gibt.
Also sprich, das ist, selbst
wenn das jetzt erstmal auf den ersten Blick clever
gemacht ist, weil Apple ja Big Brain
ist, mit diesen
Staffelungen, dass du immer denkst, ah, das geht noch,
ah, das geht noch, ah, das geht noch,
ist das schwachsinnig.
Ja, ist total schwachsinnig. Und das ist auch
der Grund, warum die keine
Micro-SD-Karten-Dinger einbauen.
Weil,
stellt euch mal vor, wie viele
Leute würden ernsthaft das
Speicher-Upgrade kaufen, wenn man
da SD-Karten oder Micro-SD-Karten
reinmachen könnte. Selbst,
wenn man eine wirklich gute Micro-SD-Karte
nimmt, die, die kostet,
die kostet ein bisschen mehr und die mag
vielleicht nicht so gut sein, wie der Flash,
der da drin ist, aber für die
Musik zum Speichern,
ja, ist das vollkommen
ausreichend. Und es hat den Vorteil,
man könnte theoretisch sogar mehrere
Micro-SD-Karten mitnehmen und immer das reinmachen,
was man gerade braucht. Also,
das hat schon seinen Grund und eigentlich
ist es ziemlich userunfreundlich, dass man
keinen SD-Kartenleser hat.
Ich weiß gar nicht, gibt es
fürs iPad einen Micro-SD-Karten-Reader?
So irgendwas für Lightning
oder so? Kann man das
an iPad machen?
Ja, gut, guckt mal hier.
Also, das kann man natürlich machen.
Es sieht halt ein bisschen scheiße aus,
wenn das da auch noch so raus
raus
pimmelt, ja, keine Ahnung.
Ähm,
aber ist von uns.
Also, es ist auf jeden Fall
die preislich bessere Investition,
als das abzugrainen.
Ähm, die Sache ist nur
die, dadurch, dass die ja mittlerweile
auch so extrem beschränkt sind, was
Schnittstellen angeht,
und du hast ja kein,
du hast ja keinen Klinkenstecker
mehr, das heißt, wenn du nicht gerade,
wenn du nicht gerade Bluetooth-Kopfhörer hast,
kannst du halt keine Micro-SD-Karte reinmachen
und gleichzeitig Kopfhörer anschließen,
was ja eh nur noch mit so einem komischen Dongle geht.
Dann musst du dir wieder irgendein Multifunktionsgerät
Ding kaufen, was das alles
in einem hat. Also, userfreundlich ist es
nicht, Apple weiß das auch.
Und deswegen bietet Apple für 100 Euro
einen Speicherupgrade an, was eigentlich
viel, viel, viel, viel, viel zu teuer ist
und machen keine Micro-SD-Karten rein.
Naja.
USB-C kann man nicht an diese Lightning-Anschlüsse stecken.
Äh, ich glaube, reinpassen
tut das nicht, aber ich,
also, lademäßig gibt's auf jeden Fall
Adapter, wie's datenmäßig aussieht,
ehrlich gesagt, keine Ahnung.
Ach, guck mal, gibt's sogar von
Apple fertige Dinger.
Das ist natürlich wahrscheinlich viel zu teuer.
Warum woll-
Ey, das ist, das ist, das ist echt Apple-
Apple-Logic, dass das so teuer ist.
Warte mal.
Apple Lightning to USB.
Der Speicher in der höheren Variante ist meistens auch
schneller, ja, selbst wenn, das ist überhaupt,
wirst du nicht merken.
What?!
Apple, please!
Sind die noch ganz, sind die noch
irgendwie...
Ach so, okay, das ist...
Ja, aber trotzdem. Hallo!
45 Euro!
Was ist denn das?
HDMI, oder...
Ist das USB-C? USB-C und?
Und was?
Was ist das, linke?
Normaler USB, oder was ist das?
Ist das links normaler USB und
rechts ein USB-C? Man erkennt's ja nicht immer richtig.
Können ja mal richtige Fotos machen.
Oder ist das ne SD-Karte links?
Ah, hier, SD.
Das ist links ein SD-Kartenleser
und das ist rechts ein USB-C.
Das heißt, dann hast du richtig krasses Dongle-Live-
Alter, ich hab irgendwas im Hals, ey.
Bonk, KS!
So.
Meine Güte, ey.
Aber das ist schon echt wieder krass überzogener
Preis bei Apple.
Aber sind wir ja gewohnt, ey, ist ja nichts Neues.
Ist ja nichts Neues.
Excellent.
So, jetzt haben wir uns lange genug damit beschäftigt,
Chat. Habe ich irgendwas übersehen?
Ja, genau.
Das können die aber echt gut.
Also Apple schafft das wirklich,
dich von einem 379 Euro
iPad zu einem
1200 Euro iPad zu gebaten.
Und du freust dich dann auch noch
drüber, dass du es bezahlen darfst.
Kann man machen, ja. Wobei
SD-Karten halt unverhältnismäßig teurer werden
ab einer gewissen Größe.
Was ist denn so die größte Micro-SD, die es gibt?
Ein Terabyte oder so?
Zwei? Gibt's schon zwei Terabyte?
Nee, oder?
Ah, nee.
Ein Terabyte, ein Terabyte.
Das ist aber halt auch unverhältnismäßig teuer,
der Kram, ne?
Aber gut, es gibt's, es gibt's.
Ich wüsste jetzt so spontan nicht.
Außer ich würde ganz viele
Filme machen mit meiner Kamera oder so.
Wofür ich mir unbedingt
eine Terabyte Micro-SD kaufen müsste.
Da würde ich
lieber
preis-leistungsmäßig eine 128G
oder eine 256G nehmen.
Und austauschen.
Ja.
Vielleicht sogar 128G
besser.
Ja, 128G ist preis-leistungsmäßig
deutlich besser. Guck mal.
128G ist so der
Sweetspot wahrscheinlich, was
Micro-SD-Kartenpreise und Größen angeht.
Okay, ich glaube, ich habe nichts übersehen.
Das Meta-Pad.
Was ist das denn?
Ach nee, nicht Meta, Mate.
Mate-Pad, nicht Meta-Pad.
Wie lange gibt's Updates?
Estlicher Hintergrund.
Gut, nicht, dass das jetzt schlimm wäre.
Haben die noch einen Klinkgestecker?
Die zeigen es ja nicht von vorne.
Komische überstehende Kamera.
Haben die noch einen Klinkgestecker?
Scheint nicht, hä?
Ah doch, Kopfhörer.
Doch, die haben noch einen Klinkgestecker.
Excellent.
Na gut.
So, ich glaube, ich habe nichts.
Was, wie teuer bist du?
Willst du wissen, wie viele Subs ich habe?
Wir können nachher eine Runde Subscriber raten.
Gibt es Tablets außer iPads, die was taugen?
Naja, wie gesagt,
ich habe jede Menge Tablets
hier schon durchprobiert, aber das waren halt alles auch keine
hochpreisigen Android-Tablets.
Die haben mir alle nicht gefallen.
Und ich finde das iPad eigentlich immer noch am besten.
Aber es gibt sicherlich auch iPads, die man
sich geben kann.
Es gibt sicherlich auch Tablets, die man sich geben kann
als Android-Tablets, aber
ich kenne bisher keins.
Exquisite Subscription
hier wieder.
Video zum iPad eher.
Ich warte mal ab, was Apple bei ihrem Event
vorstellt und dann gucke ich mal, was ich
kaufe.
Okay, ich habe nichts übersehen. Exquisite.
Der Pretzelsnacker.
Zwei Monate, danke schön für den Sub.
Big Brain Subscription
hier.
Pipo Fett.
So, also, was gucken wir uns jetzt da?
Ein paar Runde YouTube-Videos an.
Also, was haben wir denn hier?
Doom on a Commercial Kitchen Appliance.
Das ist mir jetzt zu lang.
Oh, komm Leute, wir lassen uns gebaden.
Wir lassen uns wieder gebaden von LevelCap.
Der sagt, hast du das neueste Simplicissimus-Video?
Nee.
Aber das kann sogar sein, dass ich das offen habe.
Ach, das da.
Das habe ich tatsächlich offen hier.
Guck da.
Wobei ich das mit dem Logo-Design auch echt
fail, also
ich finde auch, das zu Firefox-Logo-Design
finde ich auch fail.
Die hatten mal, ich glaube,
das hat er doch hier im Thumbnail drin, ne?
Genau.
Den Firefox-Trick.
Dafür ist Firefox tatsächlich ganz gut.
Firefox auto-playt Videos nämlich nicht,
wenn man sich das...
Firefox auto-playt Videos nicht.
Warum hat Firefox eben das Video auto-playt?
Was soll das?
Excellent.
Also, wenn man sich das mal als
angucken will, ist Firefox eigentlich am besten,
weil da startet das Video nicht.
Also, das ist by the way gar nicht das
aktuelle Firefox-Logo.
Also das aktuelle Firefox-Logo ist das da.
Aber
die Entwicklung hier ist
abzusehen, ja.
Ich glaube, das ist Firefox-Serve-Android.
Oder wie das Ding heißt.
Firefox-Android-Logo.
Ich glaube, falls das überhaupt eins ist.
Könnte auch das
Company-Logo sein, ich weiß es gar nicht.
Mozilla...
Ja.
Das ist das Mozilla-Logo, genau.
Zumindest...
Zumindest der Trend ist
klar und da ist es nicht das
da sind es nicht die einzigen, die diesen Trend
verfolgen mit
Icons. Gucken wir uns das gleich an.
Ich muss ehrlich sagen, ich fand das 2017-Logo
am besten. Das 2017er-Logo
war, finde ich, die beste Mischung aus
diesem klassischen Firefox-Logo.
Das sah ja früher noch
anders aus.
Firefox-Browser
0.6
oder so.
Das war noch zur Zeit, wo es Firebird hieß.
Naja, und
ich muss sagen, das 2017-Logo gefällt mir
ehrlich gesagt am besten. Das ist auch
noch, finde ich, von den Farben her
scheiße. Das ist dunkles Blau
und dann das Firefox schön dazu.
Das Neue ist so, es ist halt
so ein Logo im aktuellen
Logo-Zeitgeist irgendwie.
Da versucht man mehr
so weiche,
so weiche, sanfte Farbverläufe
und nicht so viele Unterschiede zu haben und so was.
Das sieht man bei vielen Logos,
wenn man hier durchguckt.
Okay, außer bei Microsoft. Die können es mit Logos
gar nicht. Nutzt überhaupt noch
jemand Firefox? Ja, ich verwende es unter Linux als
Default-Browser, aber ich habe immer
weniger Grund für.
Na gut.
Gucken wir gleich.
Also, mit was?
Genau, du musst die Logos skalierbaren können und es ist
natürlich auch da,
sicherlich, also, denke ich mal
zumindest, ich kenne da keine Usability-Studien
oder sonst was zu,
weil die User das besser finden. Also,
gerade die Noob-User finden das sicherlich besser.
Wenn das irgendwie so,
weiß nicht, so
modern und
wenn das Logo schon nach wenig Komplexität
aussieht, verbinden die Leute
damit wahrscheinlich auch eine Software, die sich gut
verwenden lassen
wird, könnte ich mir vorstellen.
So, also, was können wir uns von angucken?
Doom on a Commercial Kitchen Appliance.
Wir lassen uns, nein, wir lassen uns
jetzt gebaten, Leute, wir lassen
uns gebaten von LevelCap
und lassen jetzt
genau uns 30 Sekunden
was über das neue Battlefield erzählen, was absolut
nicht gesichert ist und total
nichtssagend ist und dann andere Dinger
und wir haben uns wieder gebaten lassen, das Video
zu gucken. Welchen Browser kann
man für Otto normal doof empfehlen? Einfach Chrome,
gut ist. Firefox kannst du auch verwenden,
das ist kein Ding, also, das geht eigentlich
beides ohne Probleme.
Aber, ähm,
ich glaub, Firefox hat mittlerweile
wie viel? 70% Share oder 80%
oder so?
Wir lassen uns erstmal gebaten.
Alter, was geht?
Übrigens, ich glaube auch,
dass demnächst ein Battlefield 6 Trailer kommt.
Allein schon, wenn die das wirklich
Ende des Jahres releasen wollen. Die werden das wahrscheinlich
entweder vor Call of Duty oder so in dem Dreh
releasen wollen. Wenn's nach denen geht, eventuell
wahrscheinlich, also, ich denke mal, dass sie's wahrscheinlich sogar
einen Monat vorher releasen wollen. So, bisschen Schiss.
Haben sie ja. Aber, ähm,
die müssen's ja langsam mal releasen. Es gibt
dieses Jahr keine großartigen Messen,
wie das Corona
stellt. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie's mit der E3 dieses
Jahr aussieht. Außerdem ist die bissl spät.
Oder, wobei, nee, verwechsel ich
das jetzt. Wann ist die E3 normalerweise?
Äh, Juni. Ja, nee,
das ist ehrlich gesagt ein bissl spät.
Ja, E3 online messen, online
jucken, kein Mensch. Hast du auch bei der Gamescom gesehen.
Generell,
ich glaube, die letzten zwei,
also dieses und das letzte Jahr Corona,
hat dazu beigetragen,
dass man mal gesehen hat, wie unbedeutend
Computerspiele-Messen eigentlich sind.
Die braucht niemand.
Auch diese ganzen anderen Messen, die's gibt,
jetzt war doch letztens in Barcelona erst ne,
ne, wie heißt die in Barcelona?
Mobile?
Mobile World?
Äh, ist auch
einige von den großen Herstellern nicht hingefahren.
Und so wird immer weitergehen. Ich glaube, dieses,
die letzten zwei Jahre haben gezeigt, wie unsinnig
eigentlich Messen sind.
Ja, zumal die das jetzt mittlerweile eh
mehr oder weniger machen, wie Apple mit ihren
Events. Die kündigen einfach die Sachen an,
wenn sie soweit sind. Aber,
nichtsdestotrotz, die müssen ja langsam mal was
zeigen. Also, es bleibt denen ja gar nichts anderes übrig.
Die können das ja schlecht im August zeigen
und dann im September oder Oktober
releasen. Ich mein, könnten da schon machen,
werden sie aber nicht machen, weil
die brauchen ja ein paar Monate Zeit, um auch so den,
das passen, die Leute auf das passende
Hype-Level zu bringen, dass vielleicht die Leute
immer noch blöd genug sind, sich die Sache vorzubestellen.
By the way, die
Gamescom war letztes Jahr auch online.
Hat das irgendjemand von euch mitbekommen,
dass die Gamescom online war?
Also, beziehungsweise, die haben online so ein paar Streams gemacht.
Ich, ich hab ehrlich gesagt noch nicht mal mitbekommen,
wann das überhaupt ist.
Ich wusste noch, also, ich hab
im Vorfeld drüber gelesen, dass sie das machen
und ich hab danach, äh,
im Stream haben wir mal geschaut, ein Jahr später,
haben die das denn jetzt eigentlich gemacht so?
Ja, ein Jahr später passt ja nicht, ist ja noch nicht so lange her.
Aber ein paar Monate später haben die das
überhaupt gemacht und
es hat
keine Sau gejuckt,
Alter.
Aber es ist genauso,
genauso witzlos. Aber wisst ihr, wisst ihr,
was die, der, der failste
deutsche, äh, so, so
Computer-Livestream immer noch ist?
Das ist dieser komische Computerspielpreis.
Das ist so
unbedeutend und, und
langweilig und unspektakulär
und dumm einfach nur.
Ich hab das
noch nie, noch nie geguckt. Ich hab immer mal
ein bisschen zusammengefasst und geguckt und hab mir dann gedacht,
okay, schön, dass du es nicht geguckt hast.
Ach, war der erst wieder?
Wusste ich gar nicht, dass der war.
War der wieder?
Computerspielepreis
2021.
Okay, das wusste ich gar nicht, dass das war.
Siehste mal, so, so gut krieg ich das mit.
Äh.
Wer hat gewonnen?
Die Gewinner.
Cloudpunk?
Das hab ich, das wurde mir mal auf Stream empfohlen.
Desperados 3?
Ich kenne nur den ersten, der war richtig gut.
Ist aber auch schon 15 Jahre alt oder so.
Ist das jetzt von 2021?
Okay, kenn ich nicht.
Sagt mir auch nichts.
Welten der Werkstoffe?
What?
Okay.
Last of Us ist definitiv
kein deutsches Game.
Ähm.
Animal Crossing.
Warum genau gewinnt Animal Crossing?
Das ist aber auch kein deutsches Game.
Okay.
Dorfromantik.
Okay, also.
Halten wir mal fest.
Mir sagt kein Spiel was, außer die beiden internationalen Spiele.
Die aus welchen Gründen auch immer gewonnen haben.
Spiele in dieser Kategorie.
Ori und Flight Simulator.
Okay, jetzt mal ernsthaft.
Nach welchen Maßstäben sind die, sind die bitte schon ausgewählt?
Ich mein.
Randomer kannst du doch Spiele nicht auswählen.
Last of Us 2,
Flight Simulator und Ori.
What the fuck?
Was?
Alter.
Was ist das überhaupt für ne...
Das passt doch, das ist doch...
Okay, was auch immer.
Wisst ihr was?
Die haben wahrscheinlich einfach
bekannte Spiele genommen,
dass die irgendwie ein bisschen Glamour haben.
Was hat denn sonst gewonnen?
Animal Crossing.
Hyperscape.
Das ist doch...
Nicht, dass ich das jetzt durcheinander bringe.
Ist das nicht dieses Ubisoft Battle Royale,
was übelst gefloppt ist?
Ja.
Hyperscape.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Warum ist das überhaupt nominiert?
Mein bestes internationales
Multiplayer Spiel.
Hahaha.
Animal Crossing.
Haha.
Animal Crossing soll das beste Multiplayer Spiel sein.
Hahaha.
Sie hätten so gelacht, Alter.
Dieser Preis ist ja
komplett sinnlos, Alter.
Äh.
Okay, warum sind die nominiert?
Okay, zeigt mal her.
Animal Crossing passt.
Hahaha.
Das ist ein Online...
Nintendo Online Spiel gewinnt bestes Multiplayer.
Hahaha.
Das ist doch genial, Alter.
Okay.
Gibt es da irgendwie einen Grund,
was daran so herausragend ist?
Nee, oder?
Grausam.
Gibt es da irgendwie eine Begründung,
warum?
Weshalb hat das gewonnen?
Das ist doch eher...
Deswegen hat das gewonnen.
Das ist doch eher so ein Nintendo Marketing Text,
was da steht.
Letztes Jahr hat Witcher 3
für die Switch ernsthaft wirklich...
Das ist ein Witz, oder?
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Das ist ein Witz.
Witcher 3 für die Switch, das kann das sein.
Anno? Das verstehe ich ohne Scheiß.
Anno ist eines der wenigen Spiele von hier,
wo ich echt sagen könnte, ja, nice.
Das hat es auf jeden Fall verdient.
Also Anno gehe ich vollkommen mit.
Der Rest sagt mir nichts.
Was haben wir da noch?
Äh.
Ich glaube, wir haben die auch schon.
Apex Legends, ja, okay.
Was zum... Ernsthaft?
Witcher 3 für die Switch?
Im Jahr 2020?
Also was ist das?
Was ist das bitteschön für einen Publikumspreis?
Da frage ich mich,
welches Publikum haben die denn da bitteschön?
Desperados,
den dritten kenne ich nicht, aber der erste war echt gut.
Also das kann ich mir durchaus vorstellen,
dass die es verdient haben.
Ich weiß jetzt gar nicht, was ich schlechter finde.
Also...
Dass die so ein Publikum haben,
die sowas wählen, oder dass sowas da überhaupt...
Warum ist... Auf der Switch?
Moment, nee. Hat doch mit der Switch gar nichts zu tun.
Es ist einfach nur...
Es ist einfach nur... Moment, Moment.
Das hat doch mit der Switch gar nichts zu tun.
Es ist einfach nur...
Witcher 3 hat es gewonnen. Okay.
Warum, ganz ehrlich, warum im Jahr 2020
Witcher 3 einen Preis gewinnt?
Okay, das Spiel ist... Ah, ne Moment. Für Nintendo Switch.
Da steht es doch. What the fuck?
Was...
Was ist das für ein Lullpreis, Alter?
Das ist doch lächerlich.
Das ist doch... Das kann doch nicht in den Ernst sein.
Warte mal, da musst du jetzt gerade noch...
Okay.
Okay, God of War.
Meine Güte, das ist so eine Witzveranstaltung.
Dafür hatten sie hübsche Influencerinnen,
dafür hatten sie hübsche Influencerinnen,
die den... die das moderiert haben.
Okay, wer hat das moderiert? Kennt man die?
Hyperscape, Alter.
Rising Headot
Nominiert ist...
Also, aber das schockt mich immer noch.
Also, da könn' ich mi...
Wann war der denn?
Vor 4 Tagen? Ernsthaft?
Ach, ne.
Ne, das... Doch.
Das war ernsthaft. Das war erst...
Das war ganz ohne Spass.
Das war erst am...
Am Dienstag.
Ich mein ernsthaft...
Spaß. Animal Crossing
als bestes, hätten
die das meinetwegen als, meinetwegen
noch als bestes Spiel.
Gut, da kann man sich
sicherlich drüber streiten, aber es mögen
viele. Aber
ausgerechnet als bestes
Multiplayer-Spiel. Es ist
ein fucking Nintendo-Online-Spiel, wo die
Helf-Internet funktioniert.
Wo du beispielsweise die Lobby nicht richtig
verlassen kannst, du nicht speichern kannst, wenn ein
anderer in deinem Spiel drin ist. Das ist der
typische Nintendo-Kack.
Ja? Animal Crossing Online.
Und warum gewinnt ausgerechnet
dieses Game, was
vielleicht ein gutes Spiel ist, aber
ein absolut mieses Multiplayer-Game ist,
warum gewinnt das bestes
internationales Multiplayer-Spiel?
Ah gut, okay. Scheiß drauf.
Weiter. Wir lassen uns jetzt von LevelCapture bannen.
Äh, stimmt.
Warte mal. Ist das überhaupt 2021
erschienen, Animal Crossing?
Kam das nicht schon
letztes Jahr raus?
Äh, nee, nee, ähm.
Moment.
Das... What?
Das kam auch noch vor
genau einem Jahr raus.
Was ist...
Der Preis ist so lächerlich, Alter.
Oh man.
Ich bin fassungslos, ey.
Okay. Das kommt
raus, das kommt raus,
wenn irgendwelche... Ich weiß nicht,
wer richtet
das Ding überhaupt aus?
Irgendwelche komischen
Verbände oder so, ja.
Okay, ja.
Das kommt davon, wenn irgendwelche
Ämter hippe Preise
kreieren wollen,
die von Tuten und Blasen keine Ahnung haben
und irgendwelche Sachen nominieren,
die es eigentlich
nicht verdient haben, aber bekannt sind.
Und um deswegen so ein bisschen
Klemmer zu ernten.
Was ist das? Das wusste ich
immer. Ach so, Elder Scrolls
Online. Das ist ein...
Das ist ein Add-on für
für Elder Scrolls Online, ja.
Das ist definitiv ein besseres Online...
Jetzt mal ernsthaft. Die wollen uns wirklich
erzählen, dass
allen Ernstes... Moment, Moment.
Wo sind... Ah, fuck. Ich hab's umgegangen.
Die wollen uns allen Ernstes erzählen,
dass
Animal Crossing New Horizons
ein besseres
Multiplayer-Spiel ist,
als ein MMO.
Jetzt... Ist das
euer... Ist das wirklich euer Ernst,
ja?
Ich bin fertig jetzt.
Es war genug für heute, ja.
Okay, also.
Guck mal, wir lassen uns gebeten vom Levelcap-Video.
Nein. Wo sind wir?
Okay, ich lass mich kurz mal gebeten
von Levelcap. Also.
Ja.
Ich hab gesehen, es gibt einen Trailer
zu Path of Exile 2.
Okay. Achtung, Achtung.
15 Sekunden Battlefield, danach irgendwas anderes.
All the rage.
It seems like a proper reveal is coming soon.
Leaker Tom Henderson tweeted
a new sketch of a...
Das hätte ich... Ach so, Moment.
Das ist... Ah, nee, das ist noch nicht mal einer von DICE.
Das hätte ich auch malen können.
Ja?
Trailer for Battlefield 6.
It shows a rocket launch from the cockpit of a helicopter.
Replies to the tweet pointed out
a striking similarity to the
real world Tanegashima
Space Center in Japan.
Tom's sketch shows a tornado
ripping through the scene.
He's previously said that...
...that weather will cause dynamic destruction
in Battlefield 6.
As for when the official reveal is happening,
Tom's sketch...
Ich hoffe, ich hoffe halt,
sie machen nicht Features rein,
dass sie geile Features drin haben,
sondern sie machen Features rein,
weil sie gut zum Gameplay passen.
Wisst ihr? Das ist so die Sachen,
wo ich so meine Bedenken hab
bei aktueller Spielentwicklung.
So nach dem Motto, wir haben eine gute Spielidee,
wir bauen darauf aus, auf
und bauen Features rein, die dazu passen.
Zum Beispiel, wie man das, sagen wir mal,
in Bad Company 2 mit Destruction und so gemacht hat.
Oder aber, so bei so Games,
äh, wie, wie Anthem,
wo es genau umgedreht war.
Und hat gesagt, oh, wir bauen ein paar geile Sachen zusammen.
Oh, fuck, jetzt haben wir ja gar kein Game,
was diese geilen Sachen zusammenhält.
Das
hab ich so meine Bedenken.
Also, es macht wenig Sinn,
die geilsten Dinger, die einem so einfallen,
einzubauen, ohne dass das irgendwie sinnvoll
zusammengehalten wird. Also,
bin mal gespannt.
...a heads-up element that reads
0205.
This could be a hint that the reveal trailer
is launching on...
...the second, the Battlefield 5 reveal trailer...
Ja, 2. Mai, 2. Mai würde auch gut passen für ein Reveal.
Ganz ehrlich, die ganzen Trailer sind immer so in dem Dreh rausgekommen,
jetzt, jetzt so ungefähr.
...released on May 23rd.
A teaser trailer launched earlier that month
and a prominent heads-up display element
had the number 23 in it.
DICE are known for hiding these sorts of hints
in their promotional material.
Illuminati liegt...
...accurate to the real thing,
he might be showing us the teaser trailer
for the big reveal.
Tom also suggested that Battlefield 6
won't have a last-gen console version.
A previous leak of the
EA Play Live Schedule suggested
Battlefield 6 is launching on November
19th as a cross-gen title and for...
...
Ja, gut. Datum
kommt ungefähr hin.
Ich hätte jetzt eigentlich gedacht, sie wollen vielleicht ein bisschen vor
Call of Duty, vielleicht wollen sie diesmal...
Vielleicht machen sie diesmal auch Trick 17
und warten, bis Call of Duty rauskommt und
Call of Duty wird's richtig verscheißen und dann
BÄM kommt Battlefield danach und ist gut.
Könnte ja auch sein.
Das entsteht und fällt
nur damit, ob Battlefield 6 gut ist
oder nicht. Das wird
natürlich schwierig, ja? Mal gucken.
Mal gucken. Also, ähm...
Kommt für PC, PS4,
PS5, Xbox One, Xbox...
Ist das allen Ernstes
die neue Xbox-Abkürzung, ja?
Da sieht man mal schon wieder, wie verkackt der Name ist.
XX. Ich mein...
Xbox One kann man ja noch
erkennen, aber Xbox Series X,
Alter...
Und was ist mit Xbox Series S?
Die gibt's ja auch.
Das unterstützt ja auch. Also ist das jetzt quasi
Xbox Series S and X oder...
oder was? Oder...
Eieieiei...
PC.
Das könnte ein bisschen langweilig sein,
weil das Spiel vermutlich 128 Spieler unterstützt wird,
was wahrscheinlich über die Fähigkeiten
der letzten Generation Hardware ist.
Und natürlich, wie bei allen Leaks und Vermutungen,
nehmen sie nur Spekulation, bis EA und DICE
eine offizielle Erklärung machen.
Das ist immer so ein... Das halte ich auch immer für...
für so ein Gerücht, ne? Wenn die Leute sagen,
oh nein, das geht mit aktueller Konsolen-Hardware
nicht. Das stimmt einfach in der
Regel nicht. Das hängt ganz entscheidend
von dem Game ab und
wie du Sachen in dem Game
implementierst, ob das auf aktueller Konsolen-
Hardware läuft oder nicht.
Wenn du ein Game machst, was hauptsächlich auf dem PC
und der aktuellen Konsolengeneration laufen soll,
und dann versuchst
du es auf der Switch laufen zu lassen, da kommt so ein
Crap raus, wie bei Witcher 3.
Was zwar immer noch Witcher 3
ist, aber halt Witcher 3 Ultra-
Light. Weil das funktioniert nicht.
Wenn du ein Game direkt im Hinblick entwickelst,
darauf, dass das eben
mit einer gewissen Hardware klar kommt
und du guckst,
dass das ordentlich
gemacht ist, dass du nicht zu viele Objekte
hast, dass du irgendwelche Sachen
halt so baust für die jeweiligen
Grafen, dann funktioniert das auch.
Weil ja auch ein Leaker
sagen wird, meine Leaks stimmen
nicht.
Das ist natürlich
Big Brain.
Das war hier, Leute,
war das nicht der Trailer für diesen
neuen Spielmodus mit Träger
Dings,
wie heißt das,
Flugzeugträger
einnehmen oder Carrier, irgendwas,
was da nie einer gespielt hat in Battlefield 4?
Carrier Assault?
Könnte Carrier Assault sein, was keiner
gespielt hat, irgendwie.
Kennt zusammen, zockt, klar.
Guck ich fast jedes Video.
Und
ich hab da auch schon öfters
Comments reingeschrieben.
Okay, das Animal Crossing Video, weiß ich nicht, ob ich geguckt hab.
Doch, klar, doch, doch,
das hab ich geguckt.
Der macht das echt gut.
Das ist geil,
da hab ich auch letztens,
ich spiel ja kein Warzone mehr,
das Game hat mich nie so wahnsinnig gecatcht,
aber das Witzige ist,
das hab ich sogar auch schon gesehen,
ich weiß nicht, was mit dem Entwickler los ist,
ehrlich gesagt.
Mittlerweile glaub ich,
es gibt zwei Varianten.
Es gibt zwei Varianten.
Entweder sind die komplett unfähig,
oder aber,
und ich glaube, das ist bei Call of Duty
sogar wahrscheinlicher, ist das alles
Absicht.
Weil, wenn man nicht mit
Inhalten großartig punkten kann, muss man halt
mit Aufregung punkten.
Genau, die haben nämlich, also ich bin mir nicht sicher, welche Waffe das ist,
wie gesagt, ich hab das schon bestimmt, keine Ahnung,
drei Monate oder so nicht mehr gespielt.
Es gibt wohl jetzt irgendwie
Akimbo-Pistols,
die haben ein Riesenmagazin,
machen Damage, und
das ist quasi die G18
Akimbo von Warzone.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Haha!
Gangway! Gangway!
Und das war noch nicht mal
die optimale Range für das Ding.
Okay, okay, wenn die
an einem Balance-Update arbeiten,
bedeutet das einfach nur, die machen ja,
die haben sich das von Blizzard übrigens abgeguckt.
Blizzard ist Meister im Balancing,
so zu balancen,
wie die Warzone balancen. Also Blizzard macht das seit
Jahren schon.
Und zwar Blizzard-Balancing sieht so aus.
Irgendeine Klasse
ist leicht bis mittel OP.
So.
Jetzt gibt's die Variante, man passt das irgendwie
sinnvoll an, bufft
gleich ein paar Counter-Klassen und alles ist
gut. Aber nein, nein, nein, nein,
die Blizzard-Logik ist,
wir passen die Klasse an, plus
machen noch alle Spells der Klasse 15%
schlechter, so dass sie danach
komplett useless ist
und keiner mehr spielen will fürs nächste
halbe Jahr. Das ist, das ist die
Blizzard-Balancing-Taktik.
Die machen, die, weißt du,
normalerweise würde man erwarten,
dass Balancing-Änderungen ungefähr,
Moment, huge, huge
Pain-Skills, also normalerweise würde
man erwarten,
dass Balancing-Änderungen, oh,
Massive Craft,
normalerweise würde man erwarten, dass Balancing-Änderungen
halt irgendwie so aussehen. Wenn hier
optimale Balance ist, ja,
würdest du halt sagen, manche Helden starten
da, manche Helden starten da, okay,
dann schießt man vielleicht bei Balancing übers
Ziel raus und irgendwie so
ungefähr so geht's dann halt weiter. Also du wirst nie
perfekte, du wirst es nie perfekt gebalanced
kriegen, ja. Aber Blizzard, Blizzard-Balancing
ist
die ganze Zeit von
useless to OP, useless to OP,
useless to OP, das ist
Blizzard-Balancing. Das hier wäre normales
Balancing, so wie das zum Beispiel
Hörensagen, Hörensagen, ich
spiel Dota 2 nicht, wie das
Dota 2
wohl ganz gut hinbekommt,
Hörensagen, ich weiß es nicht, ich
spiel's nicht.
Alter.
So.
Und das ist,
das ist Blizzard, das ist Blizzard-Balancing,
was ihr hier seht, ne.
Also, eigentlich, eigentlich voll der Witz.
xy bitte beschriftigen,
beschrift, beschrift mal y,
x,
exquisite, sorry, sehr schön.
Massive Pain-Skills, ja, so würde ich
das mit dem Balancing eigentlich machen, das sieht man
übrigens bei Blizzard, sowohl bei, ähm,
bei Overwatch
sieht man das, man sieht das bei MMO-Klassen,
Nervs und alles, die kriegen das nicht gebacken.
Und ich hab den Eindruck, dass, äh,
Raven-Software
sich das Blizzard-Balancing abgeguckt hat.
Indem sie nämlich genau den gleichen
Scheiß machen, oh, OP in Boden nerven
und was anderes am besten auch
gleichzeitig so krass buffen, dass es OP as fuck ist.
Die kriegen, die können das nicht,
die kriegen das, die kriegen das nicht gebacken.
Und ich glaube mittlerweile, dass die das zu nem Feature
gemacht haben, ähm,
dass die das sogar absichtlich in Kauf
nehmen, weil, ganz im Ernst,
was gibt es besseres, als nach nem
Warzone-Update erstmal eine Woche
Aufregung, eine Woche Analysevideos,
eine Woche OP-Diskussionen und sonst was.
Das ist doch das Beste für die, was die machen können,
um das ganze Ökosystem, das ganze
Warzone-Ökosystem am Laufen zu halten.
Ja, das ist auch so ein Ding gewesen,
das ist auch so ein Ding gewesen, wo ich mir so denke,
wie kann einem das in Tests nicht auffallen?
Die haben nen neuen Skin reingebracht,
wo der Kopf unsichtbar war, du konntest diesen
Charakter nicht headshotten. Und danach
kamen sie irgendwie sogar auf die Idee, ähm,
äh, zu klitschen, dass man den Charakter irgendwie
komplett unsichtbar machen konnte.
Ich mein, wie, wie, wie,
wie kann das sein, dass einem das nicht
auffällt beim Testen?
Ich mein, mir ist klar, dass Warzone ein
recht komplexes, großes Ding ist.
Dass da keiner mehr, dass da kein Team
aus 400 Leuten da sitzt und jeden
einzelnen Change drei Wochen testet, ist mir
auch klar. Aber solche Dinger könnte
man mit Sicherheit auch
zumindest, zumindest
zum Teil automatisch testen.
Ja, und das ist,
das ist, das ist ja auch der Grund, warum
umso größer und umso komplexer,
also umso größer und umso komplexer
Softwareprojekte werden, umso wichtiger
das eigentlich ist, dass du ne,
ne große Anzahl an automatischen Tests
hast, die du laufen lassen kannst,
um zu gucken, ob die, ob so die
Basic-Sachen einfach noch gehen.
Man kann's natürlich auch testen,
indem man die Spieler spielen lässt und einfach
wartet, bis sie sich aufregen.
Tests sind aber nicht agile. Hey, es gibt
kaum was Agileres als Tests.
Exzellent.
Oder, oder man macht
einen Testserver wie Overwatch, genau. Das wäre
auch ne Variante. Man, man möchte es
natürlich relativ schnell rauspushen, halt einfach,
die sollen einfach mal ein Testwochenende machen,
bevor, guck mal, das wäre relativ easy.
Patch kommt dienstags.
War's nicht dienstags, immer wann die Warzone patchen?
Weiß ich schon gar nicht mehr. Irgend,
irgendwas war Patch-Day oder dienstags. War das Warzone?
Oder bring ich
das jetzt durcheinander? Ist auch egal.
Also mal angenommen, Patch-Day ist dienstags,
da sollten sie einfach nen Beta-Wochenende,
Testserver, Beta-Wochenende
Testserver machen. Das wäre jetzt wahrscheinlich
kein allzu großes Problem.
Und es würden sicherlich genug Leute mitmachen
und da könnte man gleich mal ausprobieren, ob das Scheiß funktioniert.
Also, wäre jetzt
kein großes Ding, aber,
aber warum machen sie es nicht? Ich weiß es nicht, ja.
Ich hab wirklich keine Ahnung.
Ja. Das ist übrigens
auch ne typische Blizzard-Sache.
Blizzard redet prinzipiell nicht darüber,
wenn sie Sachen verkackt haben, ne.
Also sprich, wenn ein Patch schlecht ist,
man muss sagen, Jeff from
the Overwatch-Team hat das am Anfang
relativ gut gemacht. Also, ich war
echt begeistert
zu Entwicklungszeiten, zu Beta-Zeiten
und Anfang zu Release-Zeiten,
wie gut die mit den Leuten kommuniziert
haben. Aber irgendwann hat sich Blizzard gedacht,
fuck you, wir reden
mit euch gar nicht mehr und veröffentlichen auch
kein Content mehr für Overwatch.
Vielleicht mal irgendwie
nen Map-Teaser pro Jahr.
Und das ist,
das ist typische Blizzard-Taktik.
Ich frag mich, was machen denn ihre Community-Manager
eigentlich?
Außer Twitter-Posts machen.
Ich mein, allein schon,
die Antwort da drauf ist schon geil, ne.
Achso.
Okay, das ist, das ist
einfach absolut nichtssagende Antwort.
Absolut nichtssagende Antwort,
ja. Hier, so und so könnte man das Spiel
verbessern. Ganz ehrlich,
ähm,
das wär eher was, wo ich an den ihrer Stelle nicht drauf
reagiert hätte. Ähm,
oder ich hätte irgendwas geteased oder so,
aber das ist einfach so ne, ja, ist uns eigentlich egal
Antwort. Übrigens, am besten,
am besten, Leute,
das muss ich euch jetzt erzählen, das ist, das ist aber auch schon
ne ganze Weile her.
Ich hab ja, ich hab doch früher,
ich hab doch früher nen MMO gespielt, ja.
Und das war
im, grade im, äh, die waren
bekannt dafür, sowohl der englischsprachige
Herr, also der, der, das war
Mystic Entertainment, die waren irgendwann mal EA
dann, und auch die Deutschen, äh,
die das, oder nicht die Deutschen, doch Franzosen
waren das, die das betrieben haben in Europa.
So, und die hatten nen Feature,
die hatten nen Feature,
ähm, wo,
wo man Verbesserungen ein, einreicht,
so, und
man hat damals schon gesehen,
die, die haben keinen Bock, das war echt
die schlechteste Kommunikation, die ich je gesehen hab
von, von nem Hersteller, also,
die hatten, die hatten so nen System, da konnte man Verbesserungen
einreichen, und die hatten keinen Bock
sich selbst damit zu beschäftigen, wohlgemerkt,
wir reden hier von keinem aktuellen
MMO mit Millionen Spieler oder so, zumindest
die, der Hersteller selbst hatte keinen Bock sich
das Ganze anzugucken, dementsprechend haben
die sich, haben die Community-Leute
ernannt, für die jeweiligen Klassen
in dem Spiel, die quasi verbessert
Verbesserungsvorschläge sammeln sollten,
und ich hab da auch ein paar Sachen
eingeschickt, immer mal wieder, weil ich
irgendwie damals noch gedacht habe,
in meinem jugendlichen Leichtsinn,
das würde jemanden interessieren, und
das, die Antworten
sahen dann ungefähr so aus, also,
der Typ, also dieser Klassenlead,
wo man eigentlich sagen würde, das müsste eigentlich
ein Angestellter beim Hersteller sein, aber scheiß drauf,
dieser Klassenlead hat das quasi
gesammelt, die Vorschläge aus der Community
und so ein bisschen gefiltert, da waren auch
echt gute Sachen dabei, so,
und das war so geil, die haben dann einmal im Monat
hat der Hersteller auf diese Vorschläge
geantwortet, und das war jeden Monat so
richtig voll in your face, ja,
die haben einfach die Vorschläge genommen,
und haben unter
99% haben die geschrieben
nein, in irgendeiner anderen,
in irgendeiner Art und Weise, die haben sich dann immer
die hatten so drei Standardsätze,
die haben geschrieben, no, this is
by design, no,
design decision, oder irgendwas
anderes, no
balancing issues, die hatten so diese drei
Antworten, und die haben quasi jeden Monat
das, was die Spieler eingeschickt haben,
und was die Leute sich
in ihrer Freizeit hingesetzt haben, aufbereitet
haben, als quasi Verbesserungsvorschlägeliste,
wo der Hersteller vorher sogar
gesagt hat, sie
wollen sowas haben, haben die wirklich
jeden einzelnen Vorschlag
abgelehnt mit einem dieser drei Copy-Paste
Sachen, und es hat mich
damals so abgefuckt,
dass ich denen meine übelste Flame-Mail geschrieben
hab, hab ich natürlich auch keine E-Mail
bekommen, und
ich hab mich damals auch übelst
reinsteigern können in sowas, ich hab die
ich hab die damals übelst beleidigt vermählt,
richtig hängen geblieben, ja
richtig hängen geblieben, aber
ich war halt damals, wie ich schon öfters
gesagt hab, wie ich schon öfters gesagt hab,
die größten Hater sind die
größten Fans,
es ist einfach so, ich war damals richtig
geiler Fanboy von dem Game, und
wollte halt, dass das Spiel geiler wird, ja
und die haben das alles nur ignoriert, ich hab die halt
voll zugeflamed, ja
also
sowohl den deutschen Betreiber
als auch Mystic Entertainment selbst, das haben die
wahrscheinlich nie gelesen, aber
ich hab auch im Forum damals übelst rum
geflamed, und da bin ich by the way nicht
der einzige, ähm
wisst ihr wofür
der Overwatch
Teamleiter früher bekannt war?
Das war ein ziemlich
guter, ich weiß nicht ob es Guildenleiter
war, aber hier, Overwatch
Jeff, er hier
ähm
der war früher
EverQuest 2, entweder Guild, wurdest du
gebannt? Nein, wurde ich nicht, äh
ich wurde mal gebannt, weil ich Leute
beleidigt habe, aber das war ich nicht
ähm, so, und
er war früher EverQuest 2
Top EverQuest 2 Raider
und hat paar richtig heftige
Flame Posts verpasst, ja
das war früher auch so ein richtig
richtig geiler
MMO Flamer
und irgendwie waren
waren viele Leute früher so, und die sind jetzt, ich
ich ja auch, und irgendwie haben sich alle ein bisschen
beruhigt, das dauert einfach nur so seine Zeit, ja
ich hab die, ich hab die krass geflamed
also
aber es ist ja auch bescheuert, ja
warum fragst du, warum fragst du
deine Community
nach Verbesserungsvorschlägen, und schreibst
dann zu jedem, äh, zu jedem
Verbesserungsvorschlag, ähm
no, warte mal, ich versuch euch mal so ein
so ein Report zu zeigen, äh
no
design
sein
decision, ich weiß gar nicht, wie man das schreibt
ich weiß gar nicht, ob es überhaupt sowas noch gibt
no design decision
hier wird sich noch, hier wird
pli
eh, auf Französisch, Alter
Team Lead Reports, ja
das war so fail
ich weiß, das interessiert euch nicht, aber ich muss jetzt cool
Story Bro machen, äh
keine Ahnung
the fuck
das, ey, das, okay
das findet man heute nicht mehr
design decision
ich kann's ja mal schreiben
das findet man heute nicht mehr
naja, zumindest
zumindest der Hersteller hat zu jedem Punkt immer geschrieben
no
okay, gucken wir mal weiter
und, und
warum ich das alles
erzählt hab, daran erinnert mich das irgendwie ein bisschen
neun unerkannt
...
sein mag, aber im Prinzip haben die ja nur zwei Maps, wenn ich das richtig sehe. Die
haben die eine kleinere Map, die mit Cold War gekommen ist, dieses Island und die haben
Verdansk, das war's. Oder? Ist auch Free-to-Play, was erwartet man? Naja, Puppke, okay, Puppke
muss man kaufen, Apex ist auch Free-to-Play und außerdem ist Free-to-Play ja gar kein
Argument. Man muss sich mal entscheiden, für was jetzt Free-to-Play eigentlich ein Argument
sein soll. Also ist es entweder, werden die Leute abgezockt, weil zu viel Geld oder muss
man sich mit zu wenig Inhalten zufrieden geben, weil zu wenig Geld. Ja was denn jetzt? Also
und gerade Free-to-Play macht Shitload of Geld für die.
Also kann man nicht sagen, oh es ist Free-to-Play, es gibt zu wenig Maps, gerade weil es Free-to-Play
ist und die massig Kohle machen, sollten sie mal ordentlich Content ranbringen und nicht
seit über einem Jahr auf dem gleichen Kram rumreiten.
Ich glaube Zombies ist das, was ich am längsten gespielt habe von Cold War. Also irgendwie
vier Stunden oder so, das war's.
Mehr nicht. Achso doch, die Kampagne habe ich durchgespielt. Die Kampagne war sogar
ganz gut, aber ist doch deutlich hinter den Möglichkeiten zurückgeblieben.
Und das war quaetsch.
Achtung!
Okay.
Hab ich nicht mehr gespielt die letzten zwei Seasons.
Welche Kampagne haben wir dabei?
Okay.
So.
Was?
Also wenn das schon das Distress, das Disastrous ist, dann weiß ich auch nicht.
Also es ist ja, es ist jetzt ja nichts Gamebreaking.
Es ist halt einfach kacke, dass man nicht spielen kann, ja.
Aber Disastrous würde ich jetzt mal, ist vielleicht ein bisschen übertrieben.
Okay, das ist Fail.
Haben die, haben die Geld fürs Sponsoring bekommen?
Stellt, stellt euch mal vor, ein Hersteller und ihr macht aus, äh, Sponsor-Stream um elf.
Ihr lockt euch um elf ein und das Game ist down.
Ihr wartet eine halbe Stunde und das Game ist immer noch down.
Und dann?
Easy Money.
Ah.
Das stimmt.
Die haben, die haben die Streamer, die haben die Streamer in die Queue vorgeschoben.
Wieso? Dafür muss man sich doch nicht entschuldigen.
Das finde ich vollkommen, äh, vollkommen legitim.
Wer sich da drüber aufregt, der hat, äh, glaube ich, nicht, nicht, nicht, nicht mal zwei Sekunden versucht reinzusetzen,
ist, so ein Spiel zu betreiben.
Ja, aber nicht nur Streamer, auch deren Freunde.
Ja, okay, da kann man sich jetzt drüber streiten.
Je nachdem, ob das Group-Content ist oder nicht.
Also, wenn das Group-Content ist, dann verstehe ich.
Ähm, ja, aber dass man die Streamer vorzieht, das ist voll, voll logisch, ja.
Ja, ja.
Das ist immer so eine geile Antwort, ja.
Future, äh, äh, äh, dass, dass das in Zukunft nicht mehr passieren wird.
Es ist ja nicht so, als hätten die das jetzt absichtlich gemacht, ja.
Hätten die das absichtlich gemacht, dass das so kack lautscht, dann könnte man es in Zukunft quasi vermeiden.
Oder man kann, man kann eventuell das vorbeugen, was man diesmal verkackt hat.
Aber man kann doch nicht sagen, ja, ja, das kommt in Zukunft nicht mehr vor.
Das ist einfach Beruhigungstaktik und es wird immer mal Probleme kommen, zu Problemen kommen.
Und solange das ordentlich gehandelt wird vom Hersteller, finde ich, ist das auch überhaupt kein Problem.
Ich finde, ich finde, das ist wirklich kein Ding.
Ich bin auch der Meinung, dass es Hersteller durchaus mal verkacken dürfen, ja, sei es mit Sachen, die nicht laufen, irgendwelchen Bugs oder sonstigen Dingen, wichtig ist, wie damit umgegangen wird, ja, wenn natürlich dann die Blizzard-Taktik gemacht wird oder die Ravensoft-Taktik, wir patchen das nach zwei Wochen und sagen in der ganzen Zeit nichts, das ist natürlich kacke, ja, aber wenn man das ordentlich handelt, ja, und ordentlich mit den Leuten, die spielen wollen, kommuniziert und nicht unrealistische Dinger erzählt, so nach dem Motto,
bitte versucht mal euren Router neu zu starten und guckt, ob das Logging geht, das fuckt mich nämlich immer ab, das ist eine Sache, die mir richtig auf den Sack geht, wenn Hersteller versuchen oder generell Leute, die es verkackt haben, davon abzulenken, dass es an ihnen liegt, so nach dem Motto, man launcht ein neues Addon oder man hat irgendwie einen Bug drin und die Leute können nicht einloggen, die Leute backen rum, die Leute laggen, crashen, was auch immer und wenn die sich dann an den Hersteller wenden oder im Forum posten oder so und wenn dann die Hersteller darauf antworten,
so nach dem Motto, check doch mal euren Router, installier doch mal das Game neu, mach mal einen Registry-Cleaner und sowas, das fuckt mich immer ab, wenn sie genau wissen, dass es an ihnen liegt, aber quasi um Zeit zu schinden, die Leute erstmal irgendwie sinnlose Fixaktionen machen lässt, von denen man genau weiß, sie bringen nichts.
Ja, gut, äh, der Multiplayer, der Multiplayer von Assassin's Creed hat mich hier nicht gejuckt.
Ghost Recon Future Soldier, oh mein Gott, äh, das ist ja schon uralt.
These games probably didn't have hundreds of thousands of active players, but it's still sad to see games with such an insane legacy going offline.
Effective titles will have their unlockable multiplayer content disabled and you'll have 60 days to request a refund for any in-game currency they lost in the shutdown.
Valve made a big change to how they treat VAC-Bans for CSGO eSports players.
Players with a VAC-Ban will be eligible to compete in official tournaments after 5 years.
Wow.
5 Jahre ist aber auch schon ordentlich, ja.
Davor durften sie gar nichts mehr.
A VAC-Ban meant you were barred from competing in official tournaments forever.
The one catch to the rule change is that players who receive a VAC-Ban after competing in an official tournament are still barred from competing forever.
Ja, gut.
Valve also patched a huge exploit in their game that utilizes community servers.
The bug had apparently been around for at least 2 years.
5 Jahre ist quasi vor live, ja.
...revealed the severity of the exploit on Twitter.
Before we get to our final story of the week, thank you so much for tuning in.
I hope we covered all of the biggest stories you wanted to hear about.
If we missed anything, let us know in the comments below.
Otherwise, I'll see you on Monday for another episode of Today in Gaming.
Boah.
Alter, dieser Soundtrigger mischt immer mit dem vibrierenden Handy.
Otherwise, I'll see you on Monday for another episode of Today in Gaming.
Da denke ich immer mal an Handy-Vibrier.
MMO Elder Scrolls Online is dropping real money transactions for in-game loot crates.
Aha.
The game's next update will add new optional sidecrafts.
They give you a new currency when completed.
Players can use this currency to buy any items that were previously in loot crates.
The change is likely being made because Microsoft's policies about loot boxes
dictate that they have to be earnable through gameplay.
With Microsoft buying Bethesda, it seems like a lot is gonna change with Bethesda's games.
And that wraps it up for this week in gaming.
Thank you guys so much for watching and I'll see you next time.
This is LevelCap signing off.
Aber wisst ihr, was der größte G-Bait-Sound ist?
Äh, Streaming.
Streamer-Knock-Door-Brank.
Ja.
Das ist...
Achtung, Leute.
Es klopft jetzt gleich und es klopft nicht an eurer Tür.
Es klopft im Stream.
Aber das ist fieser Sound.
Das ist so fies.
Du denkst wirklich, es klopft?
Das ist so hart.
Damit kannst du echt Leute krass trollen, ey.
Kurz jemand abgehen, man klopft.
Also, das ist wirklich fies, das Ding.
Sind ja schon viele Streamer übelst mit getrollt worden.
Ja klar, geht ja auch.
Was meint ihr, warum ich...
Listen.
Was ich nie machen werde, dass man Random-Sounds bei mir im Stream abspielen kann.
Selbst selbst geprüfte YouTube-Links nicht.
So, okay, was gucken wir uns als nächstes an?
Doom Kitchen Appliance.
Kampfansager in Diablo 3.
Path of Exile.
Das gucken wir uns heute auf jeden Fall noch an.
Path of Exile 2 werde ich auf jeden Fall spielen.
Warum Logos immer simpler werden, gucken wir uns jetzt an.
Okay.
Hat ja vorher schon jemand geschrieben.
Sollte ich mal reingucken.
Gucken wir jetzt mal rein.
Bist du schon auf das Gerücht eingegangen, dass es zu einer Kooperation zwischen den...
Nintendo und Microsoft kommen könnte?
Nee.
Das habe ich doch überhaupt gar nicht mitbekommen.
Was sollen...
Was wollen sie machen?
Wollen sie sich Rechte an Nintendo-Charakteren für ihre Games sichern?
Oder was?
Okay, Microsoft sollen gemeinsam spielen.
Nintendo und Xbox.
Ja gut, da bräuchte ich keine Switch mehr.
Aber dazu wird es wahrscheinlich nicht kommen.
Naja.
Es könnte ja auch umgedreht sein, dass auf der Switch einige Microsoft-Spiele kommen werden.
Aber wisst ihr, wovon man definitiv profitieren könnte?
Wenn die einfach Xbox Live verwenden würden, anstatt Nintendo Online.
Aber das werden sie nicht machen.
Wahrscheinlich ist es eher so, dass der Game Pass auf die Switch kommt teilweise.
Ja gut, das ist doch in Ordnung.
Das spricht ja nur wirklich gar nichts dagegen.
Grüße an den Friseur.
Ja, mache ich, wenn ich ihn wieder sehe.
Danke schön für den Sub.
Und Baxter512.
Exquisite Subscription.
Ja, das kann doch gut sein.
Wäre doch auch gar nicht schlecht.
Fragt mich nur, wie einige Sachen auf der Switch laufen sollen.
Ich meine, sowas wie Gears of War, wenn es dann schlecht auf der Switch laufen lassen könnte, Alter.
Stell dir mal gerade vor, Gears of War auf der Switch.
Streaming?
Oh, nee.
Oh, nee, hör mal auf.
Hört mal auf.
Game Streaming.
Einfach der Sack schlechthin.
Aber das ist wahrscheinlich das Einzige, wie du es laufen lassen kannst.
Die haben doch auch Doom portiert.
Ja, aber wie?
Genauso wie Witcher 3.
Okay, also warum werden Logos immer simpler?
Also ich sage ja, dass es die größten Kack-Noobs verstehen.
Und weil die Leute mit simplen Logos auch simpel zu bedienende und gute Software verbinden.
Und weil die Leute immer low-brainiger werden und mit komplexen Logos nicht zurechtkommen.
Ungefähr einen Monat bin ich auf etwas gestoßen.
Das oversimplified Logo-Meme.
Ja, das ist nichts Neues.
Der macht das wieder super dramatisch wahrscheinlich, wie er es vorliest.
Warte einen Moment.
Nein.
Hör auf.
Ja, das Video ist schon, ist keine Ahnung, das ist alt.
Bestimmt ein halbes Jahr oder so.
Okay, es ist 2001, dann ist es drei Monate alt.
Das ist auch nicht der Browser, sondern das Mozilla-Logo.
Hooked?
Ich habe den oversimplified-Trend eingeführt.
Was, was geht gerade ab?
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Ja gut, aber Twitter hat es ja schon ganz lange, dieses, dieses, einfach nur noch blaue Vogel.
Ja, oh gut, Edge, ja.
Irgendwann, nach einer guten Stunde verlorener Lebenszeit, verbracht damit, 100 Mal über den gleichen Witz zu lachen, habe ich mich gefragt.
Hm, ist da was dran?
Werden moderne Logos zu simpel, zu...
Ne, moderne Logos werden halt zu dem Zeitgeist entsprechend gemacht.
Das kann in zwei, drei Jahren schon wieder ganz anders aussehen.
Wenn Apple jetzt, ich wollte gerade sagen, wenn Apple jetzt auf die Idee kommt, dass alle Logos gefälligst so auszusehen haben, machen da eh wieder die meisten mit.
... cleanen Logos gibt es seit einer ganzen Weile.
Und es scheint einfach nicht aufzuhören.
Keine Marke scheint davor sicher.
Petco, Pringles, Warner Brothers, jede Fashion-Brand der Welt, Intel, die NBA Finals, Google, Microsoft, Airbnb, Spotify, Pinterest,
eBay, unser Logo, wobei das definitiv eine gute Entscheidung war, die Liste ist endlos.
Warum eigentlich?
Es gibt aber auch noch genug welche mit schlechtem Logo, aber trotzdem.
... dem geilen Schnörres des Mr. P. und seinem coolen Mittelscheitel.
Zerstören die Corporate Overlords unsere geliebten Marken.
Ist das nicht schädlich?
Jetzt mal ernsthaft, ich wusste gar nicht, dass Pringles ein neues Logo hat.
Wussten ihr das?
Ich dachte, Pringles sieht immer noch so aus.
Mittelscheitel, zerstören die Corporate Overlords unsere geliebten Marken.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass Pringles überhaupt ein neues Logo hat.
Zerstören die Corporate Overlords unsere geliebten Marken.
Ist es nicht schädlich für die Unternehmen, wenn alle gleich aussehen?
Eine Exkursion.
Logos sind wichtig.
Ein gutes Logo kann Interesse wecken, eine Firma von Wettbewerbern absetzen,
einen Wiedererkennungswert sicherstellen, bestimmte Assoziationen wecken und kommunizieren,
um was es bei dem jeweiligen Unternehmen geht.
Ein Logo kommuniziert nicht nur Sachen, es kommuniziert auch häufig.
Es ist auf Websites, Verpackungen, Arbeitsuniformen etc.
Deshalb ist es natürlich wichtig, wie ein Logo designt ist.
Je einzigartiger die Schrift, je mehr Bilder oder Details, desto mehr...
Ah, yes. Sekunde, Sekunde, ich muss das passende Bild rausholen.
Excellent.
Jetzt erst mal eine Runde 500 Jahre an Rotwein.
Ah, yes.
Okay, weiter geht's.
... und Infos kann man rüberbringen.
Dieses Logo sagt mehr aus als dieses Logo.
Das stimmt.
Hierzu gibt es auch eine interessante Studie aus dem Jahr 2019.
The Influence of Logo Descriptiveness on Brand Equity.
Die Studie hat 597 Logos ausgewertet und verglichen.
Zum Beispiel wurden Probanden...
Was ist denn das da für ein Logo, ey?
... wurden Probanden zufällig in zwei Gruppen aufgeteilt.
... und in zwei Gruppen aufgeteilt.
... und in zwei Gruppen wurde jeweils die gleiche kurze Beschreibung
eines fiktiven Sushi-Restaurants ausgewertet.
Moment, Moment.
... Logos ausgewertet.
Ja, ist das OneHat oder was?
Oder was soll uns das sagen?
Hat.
Ich bin ja immer noch für FiveHat.
... wird in zwei Gruppen aufgeteilt.
TwoHat.
... in zwei Gruppen wurde jeweils die gleiche kurze Beschreibung
eines fiktiven Sushi-Restaurants vorgelegt,
aber mit jeweils unterschiedlichen Logos.
Der ersten Gruppe wurde ein beschreibendes Logo des Restaurants...
Ich bin ja Trigger.
Ja, dass es hier nur Männer und Frauen gibt auf dem Bild.
Was ist da los?
Anzeige ist raus.
... in der zweiten Gruppe wurde eine weniger beschreibende Version
desselben Logos gezeigt.
Das Stück Sushi war hier nur ein schwarzer Zylinder.
Die erste Gruppe hat das Restaurant als authentischer
und sympathischer wahrgenommen als die zweite.
Das ist, by the way, das ist kein Sushi, das ist eine Datenbank.
Sind wir uns einig, oder?
Das ist das Datenbank-Symbol.
... als die zweite.
Das war allerdings nur ein Experiment aus der Studie.
Die Forscher haben auch finanzielle Informationen
von 423 Unternehmen analysiert und mit ihren jeweiligen Logos abgeglichen.
Unternehmen mit beschreibenden Logos hatten tendenziell höhere Umsätze
als Unternehmen mit nicht beschreibenden Logos.
Zusätzlich haben die Forscher...
Gut, das könnte auch daran liegen,
die Leute, die ordentliche Logos machen können,
sind erfolgreichere Geschäftsleute.
Lacho, 4 Monate, danke schön für den Sub.
... 27 Logos von Startups an rund 2.600...
... Personen getestet.
Auch hier schienen beschreibende Logos stärker die Bereitschaft zu erhöhen,
das jeweilige Produkt zu kaufen.
Die gesamte Studie legt also nahe, dass beschreibende Logos
nicht beschreibenden Logos in vielen Punkten überlegen sind.
Ah, jetzt wissen wir Bescheid.
... positiver wahrgenommen und führen potenziell zu mehr Verkäufen.
Natürlich können wir auch...
Ich brauche auch ein neues Logo.
Anstatt Keks mache ich einfach nur noch ein gelbes Viereck.
... verschiedene Logos beschreiben.
Einfach nur noch ein kleines Zeichen,
um zu zeigen, dass es gut funktioniert.
Aber das ist trotzdem noch nicht das Ende vom Lied.
Denn Plottwist, die Ergebnisse gelten besonders für kleinere Marken,
die Kunden vielleicht noch nicht kennen.
Je bekannter eine Marke, desto schwächer werden diese Effekte.
Und es kann eben auch...
Und wahrscheinlich geht es sogar ins Negative,
wenn die Leute was mit einer Sache so grundlegend verbinden
und es seit Jahren verwenden, wenn sich das dann einfach ändert.
Kann sich noch jemand an den Aufschrei erinnern,
als der... der...
... der...
... der Kinderschokoladen-Kevin nicht mal Kevin war?
Wo sich alle drüber aufgeregt haben,
dass Kinderschokolade...
Nun, jetzt kann man überhaupt nicht mehr kaufen,
weil der Typ anders aussieht.
... auch Vorteile haben, zu simplifizieren.
Cleaner Minimalismus ist ein massiver, anhaltender Trend.
Und dem Trend zu folgen kann in sich ein Ausdruck von Modernität sein.
So formuliert es zum Beispiel auch Intel in Bezug auf ihr neues Logo.
Es sei eine dramatische Simplifizierung
der Marke, denn man will eine Modern Brand sein.
Ein eher schnuckloses Logo ist häufig auch zeitloser
und kann so einen sehr nachhaltigen Wiedererkennungswert bieten.
Hier wäre unsere Lieblingsfirma Shell ein gutes Beispiel.
Große Firmen bieten oft auch viele verschiedene Produkte und Services an.
Deshalb ergibt es in diesen Fällen manchmal...
Höre ich sonst auch immer, wenn ich Offstream bin.
... auf zu spezifische Details zu verzichten.
Der wichtigste Grund für ein simpleres Logo ist allerdings...
Lesbarkeit.
Ja, okay, das klingt logisch.
Heute müssen Logos skalierbar sein,
erkennbar als kleine Icons auf winzigen Handybildschirmen.
Je einfacher und simpler das Logo, desto flexibler ist es einsetzbar.
Schnörkellose, klare Schriften, simple Formen, all das ist auch ein Produkt...
Es ist aber ein Problem.
Also nicht mit den Logos.
Das ist eine Entwicklung, die...
... auch generell in allen möglichen Anwendungen der Fall ist.
Wohingegen du früher bei Anwendungen...
Vielleicht sagen wir mal sowas wie...
Hab ich Thunderbird drauf?
Also in so Dingern wie Thunderbird...
Die sind jetzt vielleicht nicht so die allergeilsten, übersichtlichsten...
... aber haben halt saumäßig viele Funktionen.
Die hatten dann früher solche Menüs hier.
Sekunde.
Sowas da.
Das war ganz normal.
Total unübersichtlich und sonst wie.
Und heute hat halt jede Anwendung so Menüs.
Und in dem Fall hast du noch das Glück, dass die gleichen Funktionen...
... mehr oder weniger in einem anderen Menü verpackt sind.
Du hast aber auch das Gegenteil.
Du hast halt neue Anwendungen.
Die haben einfach nur noch drei Buttons.
Können auch nur noch das, was auf den drei Button steht...
... und sonst nichts mehr.
Also du hast auch viele Anwendungen, die einfach komplett versimplifiziert sind.
... des Internets.
Moin Vetros.
Zwölf Monate.
Das ist ja der erste Hyper-Subscription-Monat.
Danke für zwölf Monate Subscription.
Massive Subs hier.
Die Menüs recht.
Sind die Overlords zu weit gegangen?
Oder macht das schon alles Sinn?
Wenn man als Marke so wirkt wie alle anderen, ist das jedenfalls immer schlecht.
Es gibt sogar einen Begriff für die allgegenwärtige Sans-serif und weniger ist mehr, wir sind alle gleich Design-Philosophie.
Blending.
Von to blend in.
Sich optisch anzugleichen, einzufügen und zu vermischen.
Auch über die Logos hinaus, häuft sich in letzter Zeit Kritik an den immer gleichen, seelenlosen, visuellen Elementen großer Unternehmen.
Dazu empfehlen wir dieses Video vom englischsprachigen YouTuber Solar Sans.
Aha.
Wir formen, ob hypeironisch oder nicht, emotionale Bindungen zu Logos.
Diese Bindung ist wertvoll für Firmen und es ist faszinierend, sich bei einem Logo einer großen Firma zu überlegen,
wie lange und wie lange es dauert.
Wie lange und wie viel wohl darüber nachgedacht wurde.
Viel.
Mit Sicherheit viel.
Im Fall von Instagrams neuem Logo zum Beispiel mindestens zwei bis drei Minuten.
Trends provozieren Gegentrends.
Nostalgie zu den 80ern und 90ern ist allgegenwärtig.
Es kann übrigens auch nach hinten losgehen, ne?
Also Snapchat haben sie ja komplett redesigned und die Snapchat-Leute, die waren außer sich davon, dass die App jetzt nicht mehr benutzt wird.
Filmen und Serien.
Insgesamt findet sich diese Nostalgie auch in Logos wieder.
Diese Logos mögen auch simpel sein, aber nicht clean.
Das neue Firefox-Logo gefällt uns persönlich übrigens eigentlich ganz gut.
Ich mag das zwisch...
Ich mag das letzte.
Das von 2017 gefällt mir am besten.
Das war eine ganz gute Mischung aus clean und klassischem Firefox.
Hast du das neue Der Auer-Video gesehen?
Nö.
Das ist das erste, was man findet in der Suche der Bauer-Girlfriend-Freundin.
Na gut, die Leute interessieren...
Okay, bei seiner Freundin verstehe ich sogar, dass die Leute danach suchen.
Nachdem er das ja auch mal im Video thematisiert hat.
Die wollen einfach wissen, was da los ist.
So, ähm...
Unerwartete Ergebnisse.
Moment, haben wir nicht letzte Woche sowas...
Nicht genau das gleiche geguckt?
Dabei gibt es keine Setup...
Ah, exzellent. Guck mal hier.
Moment, Moment, die Werbung muss ich mir jetzt angucken.
Moment, ich muss mich mal kurz inspirieren lassen von der Werbung.
Weil, ähm...
Ich habe mit Hetzner besprochen, ich mache auch mal...
Ich versuche auch mal so eine Werbung in dem Stil zu machen.
Und, ähm...
Ich hole mir mal etwas Inspiration, ja?
Vorab, also jetzt im geköpften Zustand, dass wir sicher sein können, dass das die Ausgangssituation ist.
Und, jo.
Ich würde sagen, wir legen auch direkt los.
Dieses Video wird präsentiert von unserem Langzeit-Partner Hetzner.
Mit den Hosting-Produkten und Infrastruktur für Privat- und Geschäftskunden.
Und das seit 1997.
Hetzner bietet neben den...
Okay, das werde ich auf jeden Fall schon mal nicht so machen.
Jetzt hat ja jeder seinen eigenen Style für.
...Datasendern in Deutschland und Finnland eine eigene Server- und Rack-Produktion.
Und kann damit auch flexible Server zur Verfügung stellen.
Über die Serverbörse könnt ihr innerhalb von wenigen...
Also, ja, ich weiß schon.
Das werde ich in der Form wahrscheinlich nicht machen.
Ich werde erzählen, dass ich das auch schon eine ganze Weile verwende.
Dass da unter anderem auch...
...einige Projekte von mir drauflaufen.
Und dann zeige ich ein bisschen auch sowas.
Das ist ja letztendlich das Stock-Footage, was alle kriegen.
...euren eigenen, dedicateden.
Dabei gibt es keine Setup-Gebühr oder Mindestvertrag-Laufzeit.
Und die Servers sind sofort verfügbar.
Unlimited Traffic und Gigabit-Anbindung seien dabei genauso erwähnt, wie die Tatsache,
dass Hetzner auf den ökologischen Einsatz der Hardware großen Wert legt und versucht...
Okay, das haben sie bei mir gar nicht angesprochen, dass ich das sagen soll.
...gebrauchte Hardware möglichst weiter zu verwenden.
Mehr findet ihr im Link in der Beschreibung.
Das war jetzt unser Ausgangszustand.
Ah, okay, der hat einen Special-Link.
Okay, so einen kriege ich dann wahrscheinlich auch, denke ich mal.
Die müssen das ja tracken können, ob sich das lohnt, wenn man das anklickt.
Ach, das war nicht für Hetzner Cloud.
Das war für die Serverbörse.
Ah, verstehe.
Nee, dafür habe ich...
Ich mache Hetzner Cloud sehr laut.
...gebrauchte Hardware möglichst weiter zu verwenden.
Mehr findet ihr im Link in der Beschreibung.
Das war jetzt unser...
Okay, aber das ist doch das gleiche Video im Prinzip wie letzte Woche, oder?
Nur eine andere CPU, oder bringe ich das jetzt durcheinander?
Genau.
Das haben wir doch vor zwei Wochen geguckt.
Wo ist denn da jetzt der Unterschied?
Das ist doch gar die gleiche CPU.
Andere Kühlung.
Hat er das letzte Mal noch den Heatspreader dazwischen gemacht?
Der hat das doch das letzte Mal auch direkt draufgeklebt, oder?
Okay, okay, gucken wir mal.
Gucken wir mal.
Das wird auf jeden Fall wieder richtig Painschamp zu hören, wenn CPUs knacken.
...so tief im Sockel drin saß und eben nicht hoch genug, dass der Kühler...
...dann auf den Ecken auflag und gar nicht mehr in der Mitte auf dem Chip.
Da haben wir jetzt unsere CPU.
Ich habe gerade eben den Deckel abgenommen.
So ist es unten drunter der Zustand mit flüssigem Metall.
Man kann sehen, die Menge war so ziemlich ideal.
Ja, das ist wahrscheinlich das von letzter Woche.
...mal an der Ecke rausgedrückt, aber ansonsten nicht zu viel.
Ich sage euch Leute, ich habe mir so in die Hose gemacht, als ich mein CPU geköpft habe.
Er hat sowas ja schon tausendmal gemacht.
Aber das waren die...
Also mein 8700K war die erste CPU, die ich damals hatte.
Ich habe echt schon geschwitzt, als die CPU geknackst hat.
Jetzt mache ich das erstmal kurz sauber.
Wir wissen ja aus dem letzten Video, dass die Platine ca. 1,2 mm dick ist.
Und jetzt habe ich den Teil gemessen, wo diese kleinen Kondensatoren drauf sind.
Und da sehen wir, wir haben eine Dicke von ca. 1,55 mm.
Das bedeutet, wenn wir die jetzt wieder hier rausnehmen.
Vorsichtig.
Dann wissen wir, dass diese Teile ca. 0,3 mm hoch sind.
Und der Chip, den haben wir ja schon gemessen im letzten Video, ca. 0,6 mm.
Das bedeutet, wir haben auf jeden Fall nicht viel Platz.
Aber wir haben genug Platz, um dann letztendlich noch was oben drüber zu kleben, um die abzudecken.
Wir könnten die auch so...
Meine Oma hätte jetzt gesagt, sitzt, bast, wackelt und hat Luft.
...decken wie das hier, dass da kein Kurzschluss entsteht.
Weil wenn wir da jetzt einfach den Kühler drauf montieren würden und das irgendwie Kontakt hat, dann hätten wir ein Problem.
Aber es ist zum Glück niedrig genug, dass wir Direct-I machen können.
Also es wird nicht mit dem Kurzschluss...
...den Kühler kollidieren, weil der Chip 0,6 mm hoch ist und das Zeug so 0,35 mm ca.
Ihr habt es ja wahrscheinlich auch in meinem wöchentlichen Update-Vlog gesehen, dass wir diese Schablonen hier lasergeschnitten haben aus 0,5 mm dicker Folie.
Und das werden wir verwenden, um quasi einen Schutz für die CPU zu realisieren.
In der Vergangenheit war es ja meistens so, dass wir solche Direct-I-Frames hier verwendet haben, wie hier zum Beispiel beim 9900K.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass es sowas gibt.
Ja.
Das ist natürlich deutlich einfacher, weil 9900K keine Komponenten außenrum hat.
Wusste gar nicht, dass es extra Metallrahmen gibt für direkte Kühlung auf der CPU?
Frei in der Gestaltung, beziehungsweise der war sogar ausgelegt für den 10900K, aber da ist auch das gleiche Spiel, dass wir keine Komponenten...
Ja, okay. Chat ist wieder Massive Brain und weiß das alles.
Jetzt haben wir aber den Vorteil, dass die Platine dicker geworden ist.
Das heißt, wir sollten mehr Stabilität haben.
Der Chip ist größer, was uns auch mehr Stabilität gibt.
Und dementsprechend, wenn wir das Teil hier drauf legen und der höhende...
Habt ihr alle schon... Chat, Pause.
Habt ihr alle schon mal ein Video von gestern geguckt?
Und dem hier...
Bisschen Werbung machen.
Also sollte er ungefähr 0,1 Millimeter Unterschied haben.
Dann sollten wir alles, was die Platine sich durchbiegt, damit auffangen können, dass die sich nicht...
Natürlich.
Bin ich ja froh.
Letztendlich haben wir ja unten die Pins.
Und es war in der Vergangenheit ein Problem, gerade in den Ecken, also gerade hier so diese untere Ecke und diese Ecke hier, das sind so die Bereiche für den Arbeitsspeicher.
Wenn da irgendwas nicht perfekten Kontakt hat, dann kann es sein, dass Arbeitsspeicherriegel nicht richtig erkannt werden.
Das wollen wir auf jeden Fall vermeiden.
Und wenn wir dann den Chip nehmen, haben das hier oben drauf, dann...
Der braucht schon Arbeitsspeicher.
Dann sollte das eigentlich relativ gut funktionieren.
Ich habe alles im CPU-Cache. Ich brauche eigentlich gar keinen RAM.
Die Folie hat eine Dicke von tatsächlich 0,5 Millimetern.
Aber im Bereich, wo die Folie geschnitten wird, da schmilzt sie so ein bisschen auf durch den Laserschneider.
Was meint ihr?
Was meint ihr, warum ich C++ programmieren lerne gerade?
Dass ich alles in CPU-Cache kriege und keinen RAM mehr brauche.
Boot to Cache mache ich dann.
Haben wir hier ein bisschen zu viel.
Das bedeutet, wir müssen die Folie, auch wenn sie so dünn ist, erstmal so minimal abschleifen, dass die überall 0,5 Millimeter hat.
Weil so wäre es zu hoch.
Abschleifen.
In den Ecken und dann würde der Kühler nicht im Zentrum richtig aufliegen.
Das sieht doch jetzt so schon mal ziemlich gut aus.
Exquisit sieht das aus.
Passt perfekt oben drauf.
Jetzt werde ich das mit Kapton bauen.
Kaptonband in den Sockel kleben.
Und damit schützen wir eben die Komponenten hier drunter und halten die CPU auch gleichzeitig im Sockel fest.
Sieht wirklich super aus.
Also 1,72 Millimeter gemessen Platine oben mit dem Kunststoffteil oben drauf.
Und dann gemessen Chip Höhe von 1,77 Millimeter.
Also 0,05 Millimeter Unterschiede zwischen dem Plastikteil und dem Chip.
Quasi perfekt.
Sieht ganz annehmbar aus, würde ich sagen.
Klar ist hier unten so ein bisschen eingeknickt.
Das ist aber vor allem, weil hier hinten...
Ich glaube, ich hätte so Klebeband gar nicht da.
...Nase raus steht, dann lässt sich das hier unten nicht perfekt anlegen.
Wichtig ist nur, dass es hier oben keine Falte drin hat.
Dass es hier nicht irgendwie geknickt ist oder sowas.
Aber das sieht alles sehr, sehr, sehr gut aus.
Ich bin gespannt.
Ja, dann mal rauf mit dem Flüssigmetall.
Alles klar.
Kontaktdonaut ist drauf.
Sowohl auf der CPU als...
Wer nutzt denn noch Intel?
Ja, jemand, der aktuell sich CPUs kaufen können möchte.
Ryzen zu bekommen für einen ordentlichen Preis ist ja zurzeit etwas schwieriger.
Auch auf dem Corsair-Block unten.
Ich bin sehr gespannt.
Durch den fehlenden Heatspreader sitzt der Kühler jetzt natürlich ein bisschen tiefer.
Das heißt, wir müssen das Mounting ein bisschen anpassen.
Deswegen oben noch eine Unterlagscheibe drauf.
Ansonsten hätten wir zu wenig Anpressdruck.
Okay, ich werde jetzt erstmal das Wasser nicht anschließen.
Wir schauen uns einfach mal, ob das Ganze funktioniert, ob die CPU erkannt wird oder nicht.
Ja, bester Rahmen.
Bester Rahmen habe ich auch am Start.
Und wisst ihr, was das Witzige ist?
Ich habe ein Fenster im Rechner, dass ich mir meinen geilen RGB-Rahmen angucken kann und meine tolle...
Ich habe sogar Modding für meinen Noctua-Lüfter damals gekauft.
Richtig hängen geblieben.
Ich habe sogar Noctua Black...
Wie heißt diese Dinger?
Wie heißt dieses Noctua RGB...
Dieses Noctua...
Chromax.
Chromax gekauft für meinen Lüfter.
Ja.
So, und jetzt habe ich mir gerade letztens gedacht, als ich so runtergeguckt habe,
ich habe noch nicht mal die Möglichkeit, überhaupt in meinen Rechner reinzugucken,
weil ich einfach schon seit zwei Jahren was vor dem Fenster stehen habe, vor dem Gehäuse.
Also ich habe einen gemoddeten Lüfter, RGB-Rahmen, sieht an sich eigentlich richtig nice aus in dem Rechner,
aber ich habe seit zwei Jahren einfach was vor dem Gehäusefenster drinstehen, da ich nichts sehe.
Hat sich richtig gelohnt, Chat, oder was meint ihr?
Das alles dafür extra Geld auszugeben.
Richtig Three-Hat.
Okay, das Board startet, aber kein Debug-Code.
Wozu Debug-Code, wenn es einfach geht?
Das ist nicht so gut.
Also zumindest mal laut LED auf dem Board, CPU-Erkennungsfehler.
Oh, das ist schlecht.
Okay, also was mir gerade mal aufgefallen ist zumindest, ist, dass der Montagerahmen hier auf den Kondensatoren so ein bisschen aufliegt
und auch gar nicht viel weiter hier runter kann.
Oh, oh, oh.
Auch hier ist die Gefahr, dass es auf den Kondensatoren aufliegt.
Ach.
Die Dinger sind stabil.
Da gibt es keinen Kurzschluss dadurch oder so, aber wahrscheinlich haben wir deswegen einfach nicht genug Anpressdruck,
also muss ich vielleicht doch den CPU-Kühler wechseln.
Einfach die Kondensatoren ein bisschen plattdrücken, easy, kein Problem, halten die aus.
Was natürlich doof wäre bezüglich unserer Testergebnisse.
Neuer Tag, neues Glück, ich habe mir noch einen EK-Block geholt, den ich noch rumliegen hatte,
habe schon die Montage draufgepackt, also Backplate gewechselt und die Pins hier.
Jetzt mal rein von den Außenmaßen her.
Sollte das eigentlich passen?
Von dem, was ich jetzt kurz gesehen habe, das einzige, was natürlich sein könnte,
ist, dass die Teile hier zu hoch sind und hier der Kühler aufliegt.
Das werde ich jetzt aber eben testen, schnell montieren, hoffentlich passt das.
Dann schauen wir mal, ob das jetzt funktioniert.
Man sieht schon, dass der Kühler deutlich kleiner ist, also der kollidiert zumindest mal hier und hier
und auch da hinten nicht mehr mit den Kondensatoren.
Okay, nice.
Dann checken wir mal.
Mhm, mhm, mhm.
Nice.
Es läuft, es läuft.
Ich bin mega happy, sehr, sehr cool.
Und es sieht sogar relativ gut aus, also RAM direkt.
Die Wärme ist aber ziemlich genauso wie letztes Mal, oder?
Es ist doch gar kein großer Unterschied.
War das letzte Mal nicht auch irgendwie 65?
Kein Problem gebootet, ohne jegliche Probleme, 3600C17, also eine normale Konfiguration würde ich mal sagen.
Also ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass es ein bisschen, bisschen kühler bleibt,
aber ob das so einen großen Unterschied macht, ob Heatspreader dazwischen oder nicht?
Ist man im Idle?
Ich kann es mir nicht vorstellen, ich weiß es nicht.
Also ich kenne mich damit nicht gut genug aus.
Aber ich könnte mir jetzt vorstellen, so, das werden jetzt, das werden jetzt auch keine Welten sein, hä?
Sieht gut aus.
Und jetzt machen wir gleich mal einen Cinebench und schauen, ob der Kontakt so passt.
Kontakt sieht gut aus.
Temperaturen sehen sehr, sehr gut aus.
Wow.
Okay, die bleiben tatsächlich auch unter Last fast genauso kühl.
Noch mal besser als geköpft.
Aber das muss natürlich dann der Prime95-Test erstmal wieder zeigen nach Aufwärmphase und so weiter.
Da kann man sich jetzt schnell ein falsches Bild holen.
Werden wir dann alles nochmal richtig testen.
Plus ich muss natürlich den Originaltest mit dem Heatspreader drauf, also geköpft nochmal wiederholen mit dem EK-Kühler,
sonst haben wir gar keinen vernünftigen Vergleichswert.
Erster Test sieht auch schon mal sehr vielversprechend aus.
Ich habe jetzt gerade die Testergebnisse ausgewertet von der Messung mit DirectEye versus eben nur geköpft mit dem EK-Kühler.
Glücklicherweise, wenn wir uns die zwei Linien anschauen, erstmal von dem EK-Kühler und von dem XC7,
sehen wir, dass die beinahe identisch sind.
Beziehungsweise, die liegen so innerhalb von einem Grad Celsius.
Man kann also quasi sagen, dass...
Okay, Stock ist natürlich schon mal...
Okay...
DirectEye...
Okay, und das sind...
Moment...
Das ist wärmer?
Das ist wärmer mit DirectEye als mit Heatspreader dazwischen?
Sehe ich das richtig?
Identisch, wenn man die Messtoleranzen berücksichtigt in so einem Fall.
Und wenn wir jetzt mal noch den DirectEye-Fall anschauen,
dann sehen wir, die Temperatur liegt sogar darüber.
Das bedeutet, mit dem EK-Kühler war bei mir, zumindest mal wenn wir diese Scheibe hier verwenden, diese Schablone,
dann war bei mir DirectEye tatsächlich schlechter als mal geköpft.
Das kann verschiedene Ursachen haben.
Gegebenenfalls zu wenig Anpressdruck, weil das Teil vielleicht doch irgendwie im Weg ist.
Oder natürlich auch, weil der Die relativ groß ist und man dann auch bedenken muss,
dass so ein CPU-Kühler dafür gemacht ist, dass die Hitze relativ zentral kommt
und auch von einem Heatspreader verteilt wird und nicht nur...
Der Bronco, da gehe ich mal von aus, weil Intel das abgewegt hat zwischen...
Moment, also hier...
Intel hat garantiert das abgewegt.
Wie viele Leute gibt es überhaupt potenziell, die sich sowas kaufen würden?
Und wie hoch ist der Aufwand, quasi zwei Sachen herzustellen?
Musste es ja auch sicherlich dann besser verpacken und irgendwie was anders machen.
Und die nächste Frage ist, wie viel gehen dadurch kaputt?
Also ich denke schon, dass Intel sich da Gedanken drüber gemacht hat,
aber sie sind zu dem Schluss gekommen, das lohnt sich nicht.
...Lithium direkt an den Kühler abgegeben wird, weil die Kühler dafür einfach nicht ausgelegt sind.
Das muss man auch ganz klar sagen.
Und da sind die Ergebnisse zwischen den Kühlern extrem unterschiedlich.
Je nachdem, wie die gestaltet sind, wie dick die Mindestschichtdicke beim Boden von so einem Wasserkühler ist und so weiter.
Da gibt es tonnenweise Erklärungen dafür, warum diese Ergebnisse so ausgefallen sind.
Aktuell, wenn ich das zumindest mit meinem Setup betrachte und mit meinem Kühler,
war Direct Die nicht besser als geköpft.
Und jetzt denke ich mir, probieren wir mal, ob das auch funktioniert, wenn wir die Schablone einfach mal komplett weglassen.
Und da sind die CPU auch schon wieder im Sockel.
Ihr seht, diesmal fehlt die Schablone oben drauf.
Was ist das links oben für eine Grafik an? Keine Ahnung.
... komplett ringsrum abgeklebt.
Erstmal natürlich, um die Komponenten, die hier drauf sind, also hier oben die kleinen SMDs,
um die kleinen SMDs zu schützen, dass die nicht in Kontakt mit dem Kühler kommen können.
Und natürlich, um das Ganze vor Flüssigmetall zu schützen.
Und gleichzeitig ist es eigentlich auch wie so ein Direct Die Frame, weil wir halten die CPU dadurch im Sockel.
Und wenn wir den Kühler wieder demontieren wollen, dann klebt die CPU nicht direkt am CPU-Kühler dran.
Funktioniert natürlich hauptsächlich, weil das jetzt relativ kurzfristig ist.
Wollte ich gerade sagen, wenn es eine Weile ist und wenn es auch warm wird und alles,
dann löst sich ja dann auch das Klebeband vom Mainboard.
Ja, dran hängt oder zwei.
Dann würde ich mich nicht darauf verlassen, dass das Flüssigmetall nicht stärker haftet am Kühler als das Klebeband hier unten.
Also das ist natürlich dann möglich, dass es nach ein, zwei Jahren dann ganz anders aussieht.
Und damit ist der CPU-Kühler auch schon montiert.
Wenn ihr das Ganze zu Hause nachmachen solltet...
Man muss ja mal schon eins sagen, ne?
Also Wasserkühlung sieht mittlerweile echt futuristisch aus.
Auf jeden Fall wichtig, ohne Frame die Schrauben immer in ganz kleinen Schritten und immer überkreuzt anzuziehen,
dass der CPU-Kühler auf keinen Fall verkippt.
Mit dem kleineren bzw. mit dem größeren Teil bei dieser CPU ist es nicht mehr so ein Risiko wie früher mit den kleinen Chips,
dass es irgendwie verkippt und dadurch irgendwie der Chip bricht.
Aber das Risiko besteht weiterhin.
Also vorsichtig immer Schrauben überkreuzt, langsam in Schritten anziehen.
Mhm.
Bootet?
Die gute Nachricht ist schon mal, dass es funktioniert.
Also Cinebench läuft, Temperaturen sehen jetzt auch nicht besonders schlecht aus.
Wie die Temperaturen dann jetzt aussehen, werden wir sehen, nachdem ich jetzt gleich Prime95 dann wieder das komplette Prozedere durchgezogen habe und die Temperaturen ausgewertet habe.
Es ist schon hart, wie schnell der Kram mittlerweile rendert, ne?
Ich habe die Testergebnisse jetzt ausgewertet.
Aber auch da keine Verbesserung, keine signifikante Änderung zwischen normal Direct Die oder Direct Die mit dem Rahmen.
Direct Die ohne Rahmen hat auch funktioniert, was interessant ist.
Das hat man ja schon vermutet, weil die Platine dicker ist und auch der Die größer ist.
Dadurch verbiegt sich die Platine nicht so.
Also ich hatte keinerlei Probleme mit dem Rahmen oder sonst was.
420 Leute schauen zu, exzellent.
Also auf jeden Fall cool.
Also falls ihr einfach mal spontan Direct Die probieren wollt.
Aber ganz ehrlich, ich hätte jetzt gedacht, dass es zumindest ein paar Grad kühler ist.
Wenn ihr sowieso schon geköpft habt, dann ist es diesmal ein bisschen einfacher,
weil man nicht unbedingt so einen Rahmen braucht.
Bedeutet, wir werden wahrscheinlich auch für diese Generation gar keinen Rahmen anbieten.
Vor allem unter dem Aspekt, dass, und das seht ihr jetzt hier,
ich keine signifikante Temperaturänderung feststellen konnte.
Eben zwischen, egal welche Direct Die Variante wir gemacht haben,
normal köpfen, Heatsplatter drauf und dann CPU kühler montieren, war bei mir besser.
Und man muss natürlich auch bedenken, wenn ich den Heatsplatter normal montiere,
den hier, dann packe ich hier konventionelle Wärmeleitpaste drauf.
Also Kryonaut Xtreme in dem Fall.
Ja, zufälligerweise.
Zufälligerweise.
Natürlich die.
Welche sonst?
Wenn ich da jetzt nochmal Kondaktonaut oben drauf habe.
Aber ganz ehrlich, ganz ehrlich, wenn ich eine eigene Wärmeleitpaste mitdesignt hätte,
ich würde da auch permanent Sellout für machen.
Warum nicht?
Dann wäre die Temperatur vielleicht nochmal so ein halbes Grad bis ein Grad besser vielleicht.
Ja, das muss man auch noch bedenken, weil bei Direct Die haben wir ja nur Flüssigmetall im Spiel
und keine konventionelle Wärmeleitpaste.
Das muss man bei den Ergebnissen auch noch bedenken.
Also zusammengefasst würde ich sagen, Direct Die bei dieser Generation erstmal,
zumindest mal was ich jetzt sehen kann, nicht empfehlenswert.
Köpfen hat aus welchen Gründen auch immer, immer noch einen großen Temperaturvorteil gebracht.
Wundert mich jetzt zwar ein bisschen, aber auf der anderen Seite ist mir das auch ziemlich wurscht,
ob das jetzt 2 Grad kühler oder wärmer ist.
Ich würde wahrscheinlich, gerade wie ich gesehen habe, wie sehr du da drücken musst,
wie kompliziert das ist, die aktuellen Intel CPUs zu köpfen, würde ich das wahrscheinlich diesmal nicht machen.
Mit meinem 8700K habe ich es gemacht, da ging es ja noch ein bisschen einfacher als jetzt.
Excellent.
So Chat, also was gucken wir uns als nächstes an hier?
Doom auf der Cushion Appliance?
Ne, das gucken wir uns jetzt nicht an.
MW2, what the fuck?
MW2-Video auf.
Was haben wir sonst noch?
Kampfansage an dir?
Das muss ich mir angucken, was die zu Path of Exile 2 sagen.
Path of Exile 2, sollte das nicht eigentlich schon Ende 2020 mal ursprünglich rauskommen?
Weil der ursprüngliche Trailer ist ja auch schon wieder 2 Jahre alt.
Wir können auch Battlefield 3 gucken, eine Runde.
Da gibt es auch wieder ein neues.
Äh, Easter Eggs? Ne, juckt mich jetzt nicht, kein Gamestar-Video.
Ihr schreibt alle Bot-Kommentare.
Wir gucken jetzt eine Runde Lockpicking Lawyer.
Den Kerl gucke ich auch immer gern.
Weil bei dem alles so mega easy aussieht, wenn er Sachen knackt.
Featured this Lobster Lock brand bike lock.
It's a relatively unique product that attaches to the water bottle mounting points found on most bike frames,
then uses extending arms to attach that bike to an anchor point.
Unfortunately, in that video,
which I'll link below,
I didn't have many kind words for the product.
That's mostly because this otherwise average folding bike lock
was secured by a wafer core.
Das sieht ein bisschen aus wie eine Dockingstation für ein IBM Notebook.
Lockchamp.
Now, I never planned on revisiting the product,
but I was browsing through locks on Amazon recently
and happened to notice that they changed the core from the wafer...
Übrigens, jetzt wo ich das sehe,
ist euch mal aufgefallen, dass Amazon,
dass Amazon Basics mittlerweile total viele Produkte im Angebot hat,
die erstaunlich ähnlich sind zu schon bestehenden Produkten,
wo man fast vermuten könnte,
Amazon hat sich da ein wenig inspirieren lassen von Produkten,
die es schon vorher gab,
um sie jetzt als Amazon Basics neu rauszubringen.
Aber sowas würde Amazon selbstverständlich nie machen,
Chad, da sind wir uns ja einig.
Sicherlich zuvor.
...specialized tools and skills to open.
So, I'm going to demonstrate what it takes to get the new version open.
Since this is a disc detainer core,
I'm going to rotate those discs as far clockwise as they will go.
Okay, wir wissen jetzt ja alle schon, was passiert.
Der wackelt mit seinem Tool zweimal und es ist offen.
...and insert it such that we tension off of disc number one.
Once that's done, I'm going to find disc number two and get to picking.
Two is binding.
Okay, nice click out of two.
Three is binding.
Click out of three.
Pausechamp.
Four is binding.
Okay, click out of four, it feels set.
Five is binding.
Click out of five and a little bit of movement on the core.
Pausierungschamp.
Number six feels like it's in a gate.
Probably a zero cut and that's the last disc.
So, I'm going to tension off of disc six
and counter rotate disc number one until it sets
and we should have this open.
Easy.
Okay, folks, while that didn't take me all that long,
it's a significant improvement over the old version
and I do commend Lobster Lock for making the change.
In any case, that's all I have for you today.
If you do have any questions or comments about this,
put them below.
If you like this video and would like to see more like it,
please subscribe.
TheChamp is illegal.
Stimmt, stimmt.
Bend emote, bend emote.
Toss.
Toss emote.
As always, have a nice day.
Thank you.
Excellent.
Okay, jetzt wissen wir auch, wie man eine Docking Station knacken kann.
Alles klar?
Okay.
Also, was gucken wir uns jetzt an, Leute?
Ne, wir gucken uns jetzt das Path of Exile Video an.
Da bin ich nämlich echt mal gespannt drauf, was es da Neues gibt.
Ihr wisst, ich bin Path of Exile Fan.
Auch wenn ich die letzten zwei Seasons nicht mal gespielt hab,
ist für mich so das beste Action-RPG, was es aktuell so gibt.
Dazu kommt auch noch, dass es Free-to-Play ist
und sogar ein recht faires Modell hat,
wobei man halt sagen muss, wenn man Path of Exile wirklich,
also wenn man das wirklich kreiselgrinden will,
man braucht schon ein paar Stash-Tabs und sowas.
Aber es ist nicht unübertrieben, also es ist nicht, wie soll man sagen,
nicht unethisch teuer.
Ja?
Also es ist durchaus mit wenig Geld zu spielen.
Im November 2019 wurde auf der ExileCon recht unerwartet Path of Exile 2 vorgestellt.
Seitdem war es etwas still um die Entwicklung des Projekts.
Nun gab es endlich einen neuen Trailer, der etwas mehr über die Geschichte verrät
und ein längeres Stück Gameplay...
Wisst ihr, an was mich das erinnert?
Also ich mein, diese ähnlichen Mobs gibt's ja schon.
Aber von der Optik erinnert mich das ein bisschen an Titan...
Ne, ähm...
Ist das Titan Quest?
Ja, Titan Quest.
Titan Quest.
Dieses griechische Hack-and-Slay-Slashing-Ding.
Live-Cam von der Katz.
Ja.
Ja, die bewegt sich nur grad nicht.
Was?
Wie hieß der?
Penetration King?
Moment, Moment.
Wie hieß der Boss?
Ach nee.
Wie zum Teufel komm ich auf Penetration King, Alter?
Penetration King, Alter.
Was ist verbeutelt, wenn das Studio sagt, der erste und zweite Teil teilen wird ein Endgame
und welche Neuerungen zuletzt vorgestellt wurden?
Was war manchmal für ein Scheiß-Liest, oder?
Treffen wir erstmal an den kurzen Blick ganz allgemein zurück.
Path of Exile 2 wird der zweite Teil des aktuell stärksten Diablo-Konkurrenten.
Nee, nee, nee.
Es ist, es ist, ehrlich gesagt, ehrlich gesagt, es ist umgedreht.
Diablo ist mittlerweile, äh, nen Path of Exile-Konkurrenten nicht umgedreht.
Also, ähm...
Path of Exile ist das Ding, wo du rankommen musst.
Die Commodots haben auch ihre Finger mit drin.
Ich hab auch schon wieder,
ich hab auch schon wieder viel zu viel sinnlos Geld
in dem Spiel ausgegeben, ne?
Für irgendwelche Skins und, und, ähm, wie heißt das?
Diese, diese Basis...
Diese, diese, äh, wie hieß das Ding nochmal?
Diese Wohnung...
Wie hieß das denn nochmal? Äh...
Da, wo man im Endgame im Prinzip...
Hideouts!
Genau, Hideouts.
So rum, so, genau.
Ja, bin grad nicht drauf gekommen.
Äh, ist Path of Exile 2 dann auch gratis?
Äh, ziemlich sicher.
Ich geh davon aus, dass Path of Exile 2
nen Update wird, wie jedes andere Update auch,
für Path of Exile, äh, das Path of Exile 2,
dass Path of Exile dann einfach zu irgendeinem Punkt
zu Path of Exile 2 wird,
weil sie haben ja auch schon gesagt,
dass man sich aussuchen kann,
welche Kampagne man spielen will.
Das Endgame bleibt ja eh das gleiche.
Es gibt ein paar Mechanic-Änderungen
und man kann sich dann aussuchen,
welche Kampagne man spielen will,
die von Path of Exile oder die von Path of Exile 2.
Also, es wird das gleiche Game werden.
Es gibt nicht Path of Exile 1 und Path of Exile 2 parallel.
Würde mich zumindest sehr wundern,
wenn es anders sein sollte.
Und ich glaube, es wird auch schon so angedeutet.
Ja.
Es gibt auch noch einen Platz in der eigenen Truhe.
Path of Exile wurde ursprünglich 2013 veröffentlicht
und hat seitdem regelmäßig neuen Content bekommen.
Im Laufe der Jahre hat das Spiel insgesamt
zehn große Inhaltserweiterungen bekommen
und in den Seasons, die in diesem Spiel liegen heißen,
wurde mit neuen Mechaniken für Abwechslung gesorgt.
Path of Exile 2 soll die Geschichte
um noch mal sieben Akte erweitern.
Wir steigen etwa 20 Jahre nach den Geschehnissen
des ersten Teils ein, aber zur Story später...
Die Story ist jetzt mega scheiße.
Also, ihr wisst, ich mag das Spiel.
Ich habe selbst hunderte Stunden rumgecrindet.
Aber die Story ist wirklich massive Monarch S, Alter.
Ich glaube, die meisten Leute wissen noch nicht mal,
dass das Spiel überhaupt eine Story hat.
Aber das ist wirklich richtig Monarch S.
Mehr.
Vor kurzem wurde neben meinem neuen Trailer
für Path of Exile 2
auch ein 20-minütiges Gameplay-Video geteilt,
in dem das Team auf ein paar Seiten
der Neuerungen im Spiel eingegangen ist.
Dort wird erwähnt, dass eines der Fokusthemen
für den zweiten Teil das Kampfsystem war.
Der Kampf soll sich auch auf niedrigeren Leveln
brutal und actionreich anfühlen.
Das ist tatsächlich eine sinnvolle Baustelle
für Path of Exile 2, denn bei allem mechanischen Tiefgang
kam es in Sachen Kampfgefühl gerade im frühen Spiel
oft nicht an Diablo 3 heran.
Um das zu verbessern, soll jeder Waffentyp
jetzt unterschiedliche und einzigartige Mechaniken haben,
sodass sich alle Waffen...
Ja gut, die müssen das natürlich so machen.
Das ist schon ganz klar.
Die meisten Leute, die das spielen,
die werden das nicht bis zum Endgame durchhalten.
Wobei das eine wirklich gute Kurve hat
von Story zu Endgame, ja.
Kannst du dich eigentlich nicht beschweren.
Das finde ich, ist eine der weichesten Sachen,
die ich kenne in Games, wie die das gemacht haben.
Aber es gibt halt Leute, die werden nach wie vor
einfach reingehen, die sie so einen Charakter spielen,
bis die Story durch ist und dann fertig.
Und dafür brauchen die halt zwei Monate.
...anfühlen.
Zwei Waffen wurden dabei im Gameplay als Beispiel vorgestellt.
Zum einen die neue Speerklasse.
Speere sind vielseitige Waffen,
die sowohl im Nahkampf eingesetzt werden,
als auch ein bisschen Abstand zum Feind schaffen können.
Jeder Speer verfügt dabei über mindestens eine Mobilityfähigkeit,
zum Beispiel Engage oder Disengage.
Diese Fähigkeiten ermöglichen und ermutigen uns,
im Kampf mobil zu bleiben.
Die andere vorgestellte Waffenklasse ist die Armbrust.
Hier ist die Besonderheit,
dass sie unterschiedliche Angriffs-Skills
direkt eingebaut haben.
Beeinflussen können wir diese Fähigkeiten,
indem wir über Gems entscheiden,
welche Art von Bolzen unsere Armbrust ist.
Zum Beispiel können wir unsere Feinde
mit einem Permafrostbolzen einfrieren
und danach durchbohren.
Neben kleineren Gegnern werden wir in jedem Gebiet
in Path of Exile 2 Minibossen begegnen,
die individuelle Mechaniken einsetzen
und interessante Kämpfe bieten sollen.
Auch die Umgebung ist dieses Mal
elementarer Bestandteil des Kampfes.
Manche Gegner können die Umgebung
gegen uns verwenden,
dabei basiert aber alles auf einer klaren Logik.
So können Felsen nur dann von der Decke regnen,
wenn an der Stelle auch eine Decke vorhanden ist.
Und woher weiß man, ob da jetzt eine Decke ist?
Neben dem, was im Video besonders hervorgehoben wurde,
gibt es aber noch einen ganzen Haufen
weiterer Änderungen, unter anderem
wurden unsere Charakteroptionen deutlich erweitert.
Noch mehr?
Ich mein, Path of Exile ist ja wohl mal
das Game mit den abstandgrößten
Charakterskilloptionen
aller Zeiten, ja.
Neue Ascendancy-Klassen entwickelt,
zusätzlich zu den 19 anderen,
die es im ersten Spiel bereits gab.
Ascendancy-Klassen sind die Spezialisierungen
beziehungsweise Subklassen,
die wir unterhalb der sieben zugrunde liegenden
Charakterklassen wählen.
Neben den neuen Klassen
und den bereits erwähnten neuen Waffentypen,
von denen es wahrscheinlich mehr geben wird
als die zwei, die jetzt im Gameplay präsentiert wurden,
werden außerdem zahlreiche neue Felsen
und Fähigkeiten ins Spiel implementiert.
Eine dieser neuen Fähigkeiten ist...
Ey, ich mein, ich mein ernsthaft, ernsthaft,
das Game ist so über...
das hat so viel Kram drin,
du blickst da nicht durch.
Also, sag mal, allein schon der
Skill-Baum an sich ist ne Wissenschaft für sich,
aber das in Kombination
mit Gems
und, ähm,
also mit den eigentlichen Skills,
mit Gem-Levels, mit abgecreiertenen
Gems, mit Wahlgems, mit
äh, 50 verschiedenen
Endgame-Mechanics, was du da alles machen kannst,
du blickst nicht durch.
Du blickst legit nicht durch in diesem Spiel, wenn du anfängst.
Mit den neuen Skill-Gems können wir unsere Helden
zu Wehrwölfen oder Wehrbären machen,
was im Kampf neue Möglichkeiten
eröffnet und uns entsprechende Boni
wie Geschwindigkeit oder Widerstandskraft gibt.
Path of Exile hat ein
außerordentlich umfangreiches
Skillsystem. Und das ist noch nicht mal alles!
Die haben, also das, was ihr hier seht, ne,
das ist der Standard,
das ist der Standard-Skill,
aber es gibt
jetzt neue
Items, mit denen kann man den
Skill-Baum an festen Knoten
erweitern. Also sprich, du hast,
du hast dann, du hast dann, äh,
zum Beispiel hier hast du so einen Sockel,
du kannst in den Skill-Baum quasi
äh, hier was reinsockeln,
was dann den Skill-Baum weiter erweitert.
Ja, hier oben, hier oben gibt's beispielsweise
Feuerskills und die kannst du dann
erweitern um weitere Feuerskills.
Die kannst du aber nur freischalten, indem du
quasi deinen Skill-Baum
weitersockelst und so, das ist echt,
du blickst legit nicht durch, wenn du neu anfängst.
Ich überleg grad, wie man falsche Gems
platzieren, wie konnte man falsche
Gems, was ist denn falsches Gem?
Zumal du's jederzeit wieder rausnehmen kannst.
Hä?
Ach, Support-Gems, die
nix machen für, für's, ja, okay,
ja, gut, wobei, wobei man
das ja eigentlich, ja, okay, versteh ich, versteh ich,
aber man hat das ja gesehen, weil's
dann nix getan...
Okay, kann man machen.
...Produzent und Entwickler Chris Wilson zufolge hitzige
Diskussionen darüber, ob man den Talent-Baum
vereinfachen soll, um neuen Spielerinnen
und Spielern den Einstieg zu erleichtern.
Der Umstieg auf den zweiten Teil wäre
immerhin eine gute Gelegenheit, um das
komplette System etwas aufzudröseln.
Aber der Talent-Baum ist und
bleibt eines der Alleinstellungsmerkmale
des Spiels. Wo das System
angepasst wird...
Warte, warte, warte, muss ich euch mal zeigen.
Äh...
Pass of Building?
Oh, hab ich net, hab ich net installiert.
Okay.
Dann...
kann ich's euch nicht zeigen.
...Management der Fähigkeiten über die Gems.
Kurz gesagt, in Zukunft ist es einfacher,
aktive Fähigkeiten und Zauber zu
verbessern. Im Detail heißt das, dass
wir unsere Support-Gems zum Verbessern der
Spezialattacken und Zauber jetzt direkt
in die entsprechenden Skill-Gems einsetzen,
statt in die Ausrüstung. Aha.
Und wie schon gesagt, könnt ihr in diese Sockel...
Boah, wait a minute, wait a minute.
Ich setz jetzt in
Gems weitere
Gems ein. Hab ich das richtig verstanden?
Das heißt, ich kann ja noch mehr OP-Sachen
bauen, weil ich da noch einfach irgendwie
drei zusätzliche Sockel frei habe oder so.
Mal gucken, wie das funktioniert.
Ja.
Und es gab noch
eine ziemlich unscheinbare kleine Änderung,
die bei den Fans aber auch... Moment, Moment, Moment.
Jedes Item kann jetzt sechs Sockel
haben? Hab ich das richtig gehört?
Okay. Das wird ja noch
OP-er alles.
Ah, okay.
Dass man nicht drüber muss.
Ja, die wird genauso schlecht sein wie die erste.
Aber, aber, aber...
Okay, die Charakterklassen sind genau
die gleichen, ne? Templar,
Witch, äh, äh...
Marauder? Ich vergesse nicht mal, wie das Ding heißt.
Hab ich nie gespielt. Äh...
Nee, Moment, das ist Witch. Witch?
Witch? Äh, Cyan!
Cyan ist das. Das ist Cyan, das ist ne Witch.
Das ist ein Ranger, das ist ein Duelist und das ist...
Was ist das? Shadow, oder?
Ja. Okay, hat sich nix geändert dran.
Mit unserer Hinrichtung beginnt
auch das Spiel. Wir wählen eine von sieben
Klassen, dann zieht uns der Henker den
Boden unter den Füßen weg. Doch wir
können dem Tode entkommen.
Huge Animation! Huge
Animation!
Nach den apokalyptischen Ereignissen des ersten Teils
wurde die Gesellschaft wieder aufgebaut,
aber neue, ehrgeizige Schurken sollen
sich erheben, das Machtvakuum zu füllen.
So zumindest... Ist doch schlecht
gewesen. Was genau unsere Aufgabe
in Path of Exile 2 über die übliche
Rettung der Welt hinaus ist, verraten
die Entwickler noch nicht. Sicher wissen
wir bisher, dass wir uns zuerst den
Weg zu unserem neuen Hub einer Karawane
in der Wüste freikämpfen müssen. Danach
geht die Geschichte nicht linear weiter.
Stattdessen bietet die Karawane...
Okay, ich sag euch jetzt mal, was passieren wird.
Ich sag euch jetzt mal, was passieren wird. Und zwar
die ganzen, äh,
ich nenn's mal Pros, ja, also Leute,
die gut in dem Spiel sind, äh,
die werden wahrscheinlich nach wie
vor, weil das Endgame ist ja das gleiche,
ja, also zwischen Path of Ex, zwischen
der Einser-Kampagne und der Zwei-Kampagne,
die werden wahrscheinlich die Einser-Kampagne
durchrushen und gut ist.
Es sei denn, die Zwei-Kampagne ist irgendwie
aus irgendwelchen Gründen lukrativer,
weil das Endgame ist ja das gleiche.
Das heißt, wie man dahin kommt, ist erstmal egal.
Neue Mobilität.
Okay, wenn die neue Kürzer ist, dann wird die gespielt.
Darüber, ob man den ersten Teil
der Geschichte gespielt haben muss, um die
Story der Neuen-Kampagne zu verstehen,
lässt sich streiten.
Die Pass-Of-Exile-Einser-Kampanne-Story
das gab das noch nie!
Die war so dumm!
gar nicht. Also doch, ich weiß, die gab's,
aber die war so, so konfus
und, und man hat
richtig gemerkt, die haben angefangen
mit einer Idee für drei Akte,
das haben sie dann weiter ausgebaut
und dann haben sie nochmal was obendrauf gebaut,
das passt auch überhaupt nicht zusammen und
also für die Story spielt
das Spiel glaube ich echt keiner. Durch die Geschichte.
Insgesamt ist die Story von Path of
Exile, wie auch bei Diablo,
eher nebensächlich. Wichtiger ist das
Gameplay und vor allem das Endgame.
Spannend ist sie aber auf jeden Fall und vor allem
ziemlich umfangreich.
Eines der ersten Dinge,
die man über Path of Exile 2 hört,
wenn man sich mit dem Thema beschäftigt, ist,
dass die beiden Spiele sich das Endgame teilen werden.
Ja, genau. Aber was genau bedeutet das?
Für die Verantwortlichen bei Grinding Gear Studios
war ein Schalter besonders wichtig.
Man möchte die Community nicht spalten.
Die Lösung in diesem Fall war, das erste
Spiel quasi komplett in das zweite zu
integrieren. Das war klar,
dass das so kommt, ja.
Alle Fortschritte und auch alle Mikrotransaktionen,
die wir im ersten Teil gespielt haben,
können wir ohne Verluste mit ins neue Spiel.
Jetzt überlegt euch mal,
das machen die auch, um
riesen Shitstorm vorzubeugen.
Stellt euch mal vor, da gibt's Leute, die haben
da 1000 Euro drin ausgegeben
und das kannst du einfach quasi in mehr oder weniger
gleichem Spiel ein Kram nicht mehr verwenden.
Die werden ausgerastet.
Haben wir dann Zugriff auf alle neuen Fähigkeiten und so weiter.
Aber auch alle sonstigen Inhalte werden
in Path of Exile 2 verfügbar sein.
Wir können also mit den neuen Charakteroptionen
die komplette Story des ersten Teils
nochmal neu erleben.
So ungefähr wie bei Fifa, ja.
Aber in Fifa weißt du, dass du dich
da drauf einlässt.
Bäm.
Ja, garantiert.
Genau.
Ich geh mal davon aus,
du kannst wahrscheinlich im Hauptmenü
das anklicken oder nach dem Charaktererstattung
stellen oder was auch immer.
Also, das wird ein Spiel bleiben.
Schick, cool und zwar ein und zwar
ein Schmoner, danke schön für den Sub.
Bisher war die Grafik einer der wenigen Punkte,
in denen Path of Exile hinter anderen
Genre-Vertretern wie Diablo oder
Wolcen zurücktreten musste.
Wolcen?
Muss ich mal kurz lachen.
Wolcen, keck, wait.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das überhaupt noch Spieler hat.
Hat sich aber bereits 2018 einiges getan,
als das Spiel ein umfangreiches Grafik-Update
bekam. Damals wurden vor allem
Schatten,
Licht und Leuchtung angepasst.
Das Game ruckelt as fuck.
Also, ohne Scheiß,
Path of Exile schafft's,
was andere Spiele nicht schaffen beim Rechner.
Also, natürlich,
man kann alle Spiele so hochstellen,
dass es ruckelt, ja. Aber Path of Exile
läuft superflüssig und auf einmal hast du
Frametrops runter auf 5 FPS.
Das stottert dann kurz so, als läuft
irgendwie ein Garbage-Collector im Hintergrund oder so.
Und nach, keine Ahnung, 3-4 Sekunden
ist dann wieder superflüssig. Also,
ich weiß nicht, was die da machen.
... schützen können im zweiten Teil,
noch mal ordentlich ausgebaut.
Außerdem bewegt sich unsere Rüstung jetzt
entsprechend der Bewegung unserer Spielfigur.
Guckt doch mal einer.
Das stimmt.
Das stimmt, die Animationen sehen tatsächlich besser aus.
Projektile reagieren jetzt auf Hindernisse
und unsere Taten hinterlassen Spuren in der Spielwelt.
So ist zum Beispiel an Stellen,
an denen wir Feuerzauber eingesetzt haben,
der Boden verbrannt und Pfeile prallen
vom Boden ab oder bleiben in Wänden stecken.
Dies wird auch sehr gut durch die neuen,
viel detaillierteren Texturen der Umgebungsposition
sichtbar.
Wir sehen Sand und Stein, Erde und Wiesen,
die mit dichtem Gras bedeckt sind.
Durch Physically-Based Rendering erscheint die Spielwelt
viel plastischer.
Aber auch die schönste Grafik verliert ihren Charme, wenn...
Genau.
Das ist das, das, dieses Bild,
ist, äh, ich weiß gar nicht, ob man das aktuell noch spielt.
Letzte Liga, wo ich gespielt habe, war das voll angesagt.
Ähm...
Das musstest du dieses Bild, ich, ich hab vergessen, wie es heißt,
das musstest du dann sogar spielen mit einem Skin-Mod,
also mit einem Mod, was diese, diese Bälle,
anstatt, äh, hier,
glühende Feuerbälle hat das da so dunkle Bälle draus gemacht.
Sonst hat's zu sehr gelaggt.
Volatile, der, genau.
Das hat zu sehr, das hat zu sehr gelaggt.
Man musste da quasi ein Skin-Mod reinmachen.
Sonst war das nicht spielbar. Und ganz ehrlich,
das ist eines der größten, größten Probleme,
die ich in Path of Exile und vor allem auch im Endgame sehe,
also im Prinzip schon seit ich das,
seit ich das spiele und seit ich es wieder spiele,
umso weiter du im Endgame kommst und umso,
komm noch ein bisschen auf das Bild an,
im Prinzip, du siehst nichts,
was passiert.
Es ist, es, du, du rennst einfach in
affem Speed und um dich
explodiert alles drum herum.
Ja, also,
und das, das,
das geht jetzt noch halbwegs,
was man hier sieht.
Aber du, du blickst eigentlich
nix mehr.
Äh.
Ja.
Genau.
Das hatte ich auch noch irgendwie im Hinterkopf.
Ja.
Da?
Hmmm.
Ja.
Mabau...
Mabau-Ex-Boss?
Die waren einfach noch nicht so weit, die waren eigentlich auch ganz froh, dass sie das verschieben konnten damals, das fand ich auch geil, diese Aussage, so nach dem Motto, die haben ja nicht geschrieben, sie wollen sich das Release-Fenster nicht mit Cyberpunk teilen, das ist ja nur die halbe Wahrheit, die haben quasi geschrieben, sie wollen Spieler, so sinngemäß, sie wollen Spieler nicht in den Konflikt, also sie haben sich so als die Superguten hingestellt, sie wollen den Spieler nicht in den Konflikt bringen, zwischen PoE und Cyberpunk wählen zu müssen und deswegen verschieben sie das, dass die Spiele,
die waren einfach noch nicht so weit, ja.
Stonks Ausrede.
Kurz gesagt, Path of Exile 2 ist noch nicht in greifbarer Nähe. Grinding Gear Games rechnet frühestens 2022 mit einer ersten Beta, bis wir selbst dran dürfen, müssen wir uns also noch etwas gedulden.
Hey, das ist doch die gleiche Sprecherin von...
Von... von... von dem... von der einen, ähm...
Äh, wie... wie heißen diese... wie heißen die... die in dem Singleplayer? Von diesen Beschwörer-Typen aus dem Singleplayer, ist doch die gleiche Sprecherin, oder?
...ersten Beta, bis wir selbst dran dürfen, müssen wir uns also noch etwas gedulden.
Das ist original die gleiche Sprecherin!
Was können wir also noch bis dahin...
Okay, vielleicht ist auch der gleiche Charakter, kann ja sein.
In erster Linie können Fans natürlich weiterhin Path of Exile spielen.
Wie früher im Video schon gesagt...
...sollen die beiden Spiele sich das Endgame teilen.
Alle Fortschritte, die ihr jetzt also im ersten Teil noch erspielt und auch Mikrotransaktionen, die ihr tätigt, bleiben euch in Path of Exile 2 erhalten.
Anfang des Jahres erschien mit Echoes of the Atlas eine neue Erweiterung, die wieder eine ganze Menge neue Inhalte ins Spiel gebracht hat und wie jede neue Season führt auch die Ultimatum-Liga eine spannende neue Liga-Mechanik ein.
Dieses Mal fordert der Trialmaster, ein Diener des Chaosgottes, euch zu Arena-Kämpfen heraus und verspricht...
Die Story, keck, wait, Alter.
...kürerische Belohnungen.
Wenn wir die Gefechte bestritten haben, stellt er uns vor das namensgebende Ultimatum.
Entweder wir akzeptieren den Preis oder wir stellen uns im Kampf immer schwierigeren Herausforderungen, um zusätzlichen Loot zu gewinnen.
Im Endgame betreten wir gelegentlich das Reich des Trialmasters und können dort nochmal schwierigere Kämpfe bestreiten, für die wir allerdings zuerst ein Opfer bringen müssen.
Wenn wir die Prüfung meistern, bekommen wir den Einsatz doppelt zurück, wenn wir es aber nicht schaffen, sind sowohl Einsatz als auch zusätzlicher Loot weg.
Zum Schluss...
Ich opfere einfach den Chat. Easy Loot.
... wie Path of Exile 2 wurde auch ein Mobile-Ableger der Serie angekündigt. Von dem haben wir allerdings seitdem nichts Neues gehört.
Da der auch komplett im eigenen Studio entwickelt werden soll und man sich dort jetzt auf Path of Exile 2 konzentrieren will, sieht es nicht danach aus, als würden wir dieses Game in nächster Zeit sehen.
Das war's mit unserem kleinen Ausblick auf Path of Exile 2.
Wie schaut's bei euch aus? Ärgert ihr euch über die Verschiebung?
Oder seid ihr erstmal noch eine Weile mit den Inhalten des ersten Teils glücklich?
Ich freu mich auf eure Meinung. Wenn euch das Video gefallen hat...
Also eins machen die wirklich gut bei Path of Exile, die schaffen es über Jahre lang, ihr Game für Dauergrinder attraktiv zu halten.
Klar, es ist so, die Leute, die das Spiel, also gerade auch die größeren Streamer, die das Spiel irgendwie schon seit 5 Jahren oder so spielen, das kam ja 2013 oder sonst wie raus, oder seit 7 Jahren oder sonst wie spielen, du merkst das immer richtig, eine neue Liga fängt an, die Typen grinden 24-7,
für 1-2 Wochen und dann flacht's ab und sie spielen wieder anderes Zeug, aber nichtdestotrotz schaffen die das, dass die Leute dabei bleiben und bei jeder Liga wieder am Start sind, das muss da auch erstmal schaffen und das schaffen die nur, weil die es zumindest meisten schaffen, halbwegs interessante Inhalte irgendwie noch in das Spiel zu integrieren, die es so vorher nicht gegeben hat.
Leider werfen die halt auch kaum Inhalte raus.
So, oder was heißt leider? Kann man sich jetzt drüber schreiben, ob das gut oder schlecht ist?
Also, zumindest hast du jetzt halt, keine Ahnung, wie viel die Liga das ist, ich sag jetzt einfach mal die 15. Liga, ich weiß es ehrlich gesagt nicht, und die haben jetzt quasi von 15 Liga, also 15 Leaks, die sie gestartet haben, im Prinzip ist die Liga Leather Reset, haben die quasi die Mechanics zum größten Teil noch drin, das heißt, du hast jetzt gesammeltes, gesammelten Endgame-Content und Endgame-Currency, Endgame-Items drin,
von Ligen, von Leathers, die quasi...
zwei Jahre her sind, und die du eigentlich gar nicht mal wirklich brauchst, außer vielleicht alle 100 Maps mal eine Bonus-Map zu machen damit, also es ist äußerst undurchsichtig, ja.
Und dann haben sie noch solche Sachen drin, wie dieses Syndicate-Board, was auch erstmal so eine Wissenschaft für sich ist, wo du keine Ahnung hast, was Sache ist, ja, wo du wen du wie dann miteinander verknüpfen musst und solche Dinge, ey, das ist echt keck-weight, also das Spiel ist echt eines der komplexesten Games, die ich kenne in dieser Richtung, ja.
Also das ist, das ist wirklich, äh, Metamorph, nee, ich glaube, Metamorph ist nicht komplett rausgeflogen, du kannst, also ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, aber ich glaube, du kannst heute, du kannst immer noch Metamorph-Teile finden, halt nicht mehr so oft, wie in der Metamorph-League, ich glaube, du kannst immer noch Metamorph-Teile droppen, aber es ist halt recht selten, und dementsprechend kannst du irgendwie alle Schaltjahre mal so einen, so einen Metamorph-Kampf machen, das ist schon äußerst komplex, das Ganze.
Ja.
Aber ich seh's übrigens umgedreht, ne, nicht Kampfansage an Diablo 4, ich seh's eher umgedreht, Diablo 4 müsste eigentlich eher die Kampfansage an Path of Exile sein, weil Path of Exile ist einfach das Ding, wo du rankommen musst aktuell, nicht umgedreht.
Dass da Diablo, Diablo irgendwie so die Referenz wäre, ist meiner Meinung nach schon vorbei, schon lange vorbei.
Green Style, 5 Monate, dankeschön, für den massive Sub.
Okay, was gucken wir uns jetzt an? Leute, wollen wir uns, wollen wir uns noch eine Runde, komm, wir gucken uns noch eine Runde Battlefield.
Ich guck immer gern Battlefield 3 Gameplays, ich weiß, Boomer Game und so, Boomer Clap, warum gibt's eigentlich, warum gibt's eigentlich die Kombination aus Boomer Clap nicht?
Es gibt Easy Clap, aber es gibt kein Boomer Clap.
Aber im Chat müsste es funktionieren, oder? Lass mal ausprobieren, Boomer Clap, ja, das funktioniert.
Okay, ähm, gucken wir uns eine Runde Battlefield 3 an.
Vor allem Infantry Plays.
Und by the way, ich mach den absichtlich nicht so laut, weil er sagt jedes Mal das gleiche und ich laber eh drüber.
Der Sound von dem Game ist auch immer noch übelst nice.
Ha!
Null!
Wie viel, alter, what the fuck?
Wie viel hat der denn mit seiner Granate gekillt grad?
Da muss ja der ganze Gegner, da muss ja, da muss ja, da muss ja komplett alles voll sein mit Gegnern.
Ich hab das ihm auch hinzugefügt.
Der hat bestimmt noch, ja, ja, da ist bestimmt noch ein C4 oder irgendwas in die Luft geflogen.
Das ist Konsole?
Das ist so eine schlechte Auflösung.
Aber das sieht zu gut aus für Konsole, das kann eigentlich nicht Konsole sein.
Aber das Movement und alles ist nicht Konsole.
Das ist Venice, oder? Von der Farbe her.
Ist das Venice?
Ja, der Chat ist eindeutig Venice.
Ah, ne, oben rechts steht's ja auch.
Oben rechts steht's ja auch.
Moment.
Sekunde, Sekunde.
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass das jemand wirklich live erspielt hat.
Venice ist dead.
Moment, Moment.
Okay, Leute, ich tippe auf meistbenutzter Server fünf Spieler.
Ne, Gnome, das neue Gnome hab ich ja nicht angeguckt.
Drei!
Drei Spieler, alter.
Massive.
Oder auch nicht Massive.
Ja, schon dead, aber die haben's halt ein bisschen verkackt, ne?
Ähm, du kannst es nicht gucken.
Du kannst es auch komplett irgendwelchen Random-Server-Anbietern überlassen,
dass du was Sinnvolles hingestellt bekommst.
Die haben wirklich, die haben echt guten, äh, Grundlage gelegt,
aber es hätte einfach, meiner Meinung nach,
es hätte eins, zwei offizielle Server gebraucht.
Mit sinnvollem Regelset, die zeigen, was cooles geht,
aber was nicht zu weit vom ursprünglichen Battlefield entfernt ist.
Zum Beispiel so Sachen wie, ähm, Assault kann Engineer-Waffen spielen und so.
Also richtig coole Sachen.
Das wäre eine coole Idee gewesen.
Und es hätte eins, zwei gute, offizielle, stabile Server geben müssen,
wo die Leute genau wissen, okay, da kann ich mich einloggen, da kann ich spielen.
Die brauchen dementsprechend auch ein Moderationsteam,
die gucken, dass da keiner cheatet und sonst wo.
Und dann hätte das sicherlich eine Zukunft gehabt, äh, auch mit Spielern.
Aber, ähm, du kannst auch nicht zwei, drei Wochen, äh, äh, Memory-Leak drinnen lassen,
dass den Leuten nach drei Runden das Spiel abschmiert.
Das hat dem, das war so der Todesstoß, ja.
Ja.
Auch jedes Video.
Der Chat fragt, warum ich so leise mach.
Und jetzt hab ich den Anfang gar nicht gesehen.
1-4-9 in your face.
Ja.
Er hat ja auch, das hier ist ja auch absolute OP-Posi.
Das ist eines der besten Posi's auf der ganzen Map.
Da kannst du einfach reinhalten und sprayen.
Oh, wegschneibt.
Da liegen sie.
Der Medic-Train ist am Start, Leute.
Der Medic-Train ist am Start.
Was ist das? M16 mit Schalldämpfer?
Das ist übrigens eine super Posi da oben hier.
Man muss über die, okay, Battlefield 3 Tipps in 2021, ich weiß.
Man muss über die Rolltreppe, über die Seite, man kann draufspringen, hier auf die Seite hochrennen.
Das ist viel besser, als über die Rolltreppe selbst rennen.
Oh, da stehen sie wieder.
Da stehen sie und lassen sich bashen, Alter.
Ah, yes.
Moment, Moment, ist das French?
Poggers am Spiel?
Ja, das ist Poggers.
Er wird hier überlebt und dann geht er auf ein bisschen mehr Rampage mit seinem Squad.
Das ist schon ein bisschen wie ich, wenn ich spiele.
Ich bin mental bemerkbar.
Drei Tipps von Archer.
Ah, noch ein paar TdM, was sonst?
Ich habe noch ein paar TdM.
Schaut euch das an.
Die Schneiberdudes, die einfach nichts anderes machen, außer auf den Turm zu geiern.
So schlimm.
Gut, der läuft ihm ja auch mit dem Kopf voll ins Fadenkreuz gerade.
Jetzt schreckt.
Hallo?
Schneiberdude, was los, Alter?
Okay, das sind zwei Leute schon.
Nice headshot.
Aber der Schneiberdude auf der Erde schon wieder so.
Warte, Pepega, was ist hier los?
Ich bin überfordert mit dem Spiel, was zehn Jahre alt ist.
Oder sogar älter.
Elf Jahre alt ist.
Zehneinhalb Jahre alt ist.
Wann kam Battlefield 3 raus?
2010?
Nee, oder?
2011?
2011.
2010 war PC2, genau.
Genau.
Super akut, so viel von Archer.
Bam!
Oh, okay.
Da hat er auch ein bisschen Lack.
PostChamp?
Okay der hat, der hat schon mal so gut 200, 250 Millisekunden Delay.
Was für ein Notizprogramm.
Joplin verwende ich.
Das Cross-Plattformen gibt es für Android, iOS, Windows, Linux, Metro, was sonst.
Okay, wenn die restlichen Clips sind alle Metro.
Und die restlichen Clips sind alle Metro?
Und dann für den Rest des Clips ist es eine Mischung von seinem G3A3 und seiner zweiten Revolver.
Akkurate Sachen, wieder einmal von Archer auf Metro.
Nächster Punkt, drei Clips von Lackey.
Der erste ist auf Noshak, der mit dem M48 verwendet wurde.
Der zweite ist auf Noshak, der mit dem M48 verwendet wurde.
Der dritte ist auf Noshak, der mit dem M48 verwendet wurde.
Unabhängig vom ...
Eine Frage dafür.
Setzt euch der Rival V zum Beispiel auf.
Vielleicht gehts uns unraveln.
Danken.
Unabhängig vom ...
dass Smog noch immer mehr Munition hat.
Das ist ja geil.
Okay, also einen 11er Smoke-Killstreak
habe ich ehrlich gesagt jetzt in 10 Jahren
von diesem Game noch nicht gesehen.
Geil.
Aber die sind ja auch wieder planlos hoch 10.
Aber es muss so sein.
Geil, geiler Scheiß.
Da ist die Moab.
Ump, bitte Ump.
Der Own, ich habe letztens in einen Stream
wieder reingeguckt, er meint, er hat irgendwie
über 3.500, glaube sogar,
Spielstunden Battlefield.
Also der grindet schon eine Weile.
Ich habe 1.000 oder so
alle Plattformen zusammen.
Oh, nice.
Richtig, bam. So sieht es aus.
Bam.
Der benutzt
die richtige
grammatikalische
Ausdrucksweise dafür.
Wenn man gebasht hat, sagt man bam.
So wie Bruce Lee.
Ich bin es früher.
Ich glaube, den Clip kennt gar keiner mehr.
Bam wie Bruce Lee.
Ich weiß, Boomer-Memes.
Rentner-Memes.
Ja, ich weiß.
Aber immer noch besser als 90% aller
TikTok-Memes. True, lol, weh.
Aber die werden schon wieder heftig
zerstört.
Wenn er jetzt noch eine Granate hätte und die da hinten reinzuhauen,
das wäre natürlich Poggers.
Oh, close.
Close AF.
G3.
Okay.
Ja, äh, Metro
ist ziemlich
Spawn-Campy, was das angeht.
Oh.
Silence G3.
Hallo.
Oh.
Die lassen sich wieder bashen.
Das riecht in ihr Face, Alter. Bam.
Sozusagen.
Nice.
Hallo.
Die werden wieder zerstört, ey.
Okay, es war klar, dass die jetzt hinten rauskommen.
Backrage.
Sagt der Commentator sonst immer,
wenn irgendwie sowas passiert.
Backrage.
Weiß auch nicht, ich verwende das Wort Backrage eigentlich sonst nie,
aber irgendwie mag der das Wort Backrage.
Eat Snoop Bashing.
Naja, man darf nicht vergessen.
Ist es natürlich, sonst kriegt man das natürlich nicht hin.
Aber man darf nicht vergessen, das Game ist 10 Jahre alt.
Also die Leute hatten genug Chancen, ein bisschen zu üben.
Was? Asus?
Ah, ne, Masus.
Nicht Asus.
Asus.
Beste Waffe.
Ich weiß, objektiv betrachtet, M16 die beste, aber ich mag die am liebsten.
M416.
Auch genau dieses Setup.
Kodra Visier.
F.I. Barrel.
Griff.
Bam, bam, bam.
Um Metkit.
Metkit hier.
Ich hab damals erst durch dich gelernt, wie man den Recoil der Waffen kontrolliert.
Ja, ich meine, in Battlefield 3 ist es ja auch ziemlich easy, ne?
Gerade M16, äh, beziehungsweise M416 beide, sind easy.
Du musst einfach...
Du musst einfach nur ungefähr so in der Geschwindigkeit runterziehen.
Das war's.
Das ist alles.
Das war in dem...
Wir sind im Game wirklich nicht sonderlich schwer.
Und M16 ist sogar richtig nice zu Burst feuern.
Also schnelle Bursts.
Also die, die...
Wenn du quasi M16...
So in der Richtung quasi.
Tja, leider so viele Metroclips.
Battlefield 3 hat da so viele nice Maps.
Ich würde gerne auch ein bisschen andere Maps sehen, aber gut.
Ah, musst das nehmen, was du kriegst.
Zumal du halt nicht auf den meisten anderen Maps spielen kannst.
Deswegen fand ich die ganzen Venice Server cool.
Die hatten auch andere in der Rotation.
Die hatten auch andere in der Rotation drin.
Leider haben sie es verkackt.
Brrrt.
Get schreckt.
Wie kommt denn der da hin?
Na gut, der ist über die Treppe hochgelaufen.
Ja, das passiert mir auch öfters.
Was wurde bei Venice verschissen?
Ach, von Venice Seite her gar nicht mal so viel.
Man hat halt verschissen, dass man...
Also, man hat nicht sonderlich gut mit den Leuten kommuniziert.
Und, äh, meiner Meinung nach, was total versäumt wurde,
ist, dass man 1, 2, 3 wirkliche Stable Server
mit sinnigen...
im Ruleset angeboten hat.
Also quasi, dass man, sag mal, 2 oder 3 wirklich offizielle,
oder soweit es offiziell ist,
ähm, offizielle Server anbietet,
die eben ein Ruleset haben,
was nah an Battlefield 3 dran ist,
aber was coole neue Sachen zeigt,
wo die Leute halt sagen, hey, da weiß ich, worauf ich mich einlasse.
Du hattest ja nur Custom-Server von Anfang an komplett.
Teilweise Custom-Server, wo du dir Gedanken machen musstest,
ob die Owner nicht selber cheaten und sowas.
Du hättest 3 Server machen müssen,
oder 2, ein Kongfest, ein Rush.
Gute Rotation.
Gute Settings.
Coole Sachen, wie zum Beispiel,
dass Medics Engineer-Waffen verwenden können und sowas.
Wo man auch sieht, hey, das ist coole Neuigkeiten,
die einen Vorteil haben, gegenüber Vanilla zu spielen.
Besserer Netcode, Farbfilter, Suppression und sonst wie.
Und das hättest du den Leuten bereitstellen müssen,
gut moderiert.
Das hätte auch Erfolg langfristig gehabt.
Ist das jetzt dead?
Ja, ziemlich.
Mal gucken.
Also, was als nächstes rauskommt,
ist ja der Battlefield-3-Reality-Mod.
Der wird halt so mit dem normalen Battlefield-3-Gameplay
gar nicht so viel zu tun haben.
Mal gucken.
Und ansonsten mal schauen, was passiert.
Ansonsten ist es ziemlich dead.
Ja, ist echt extrem schade,
weil das Game sich besser gespielt hat.
Also, es hat sich ein bisschen komisch angefühlt,
erst mal mit höherer Tickrate
und, ja, also, besserer Hit-Rack.
Du hast dann auch manchmal durchgeschossen und sowas.
Das war nicht perfekt,
aber es hat sich insgesamt, finde ich, doch besser gespielt
und weniger drei Sekunden später kippt einer um wie Vanilla.
Die Katze, die Katze hier, die ist das Live-Live-Cam von der Katze.
Okay.
Im Prinzip das ist halt das, was...
...was...
bisschen doof ist, das gibt im Prinzip
90% die Granate macht unter
ok, macht doch kein Damage unter dem Zug
es gibt halt 90%
Metro und Norsha TDM
also Metro, entweder
Kongfest Rush oder halt Norsha TDM
es gibt halt auch noch viele coole
anderen Sachen, die man spielen kann
aber gut, ich will mal nicht, ich will mich jetzt
mal nicht, ich will mal nicht so sein, ich meine das Spiel
ist 10 Jahre alt
es ist cool, dass es überhaupt noch gespielt wird
leider ist Venice RIP
bam, bam, bam
Alter, die lassen sich wieder wegklatschen
ja
Spotting durch alles durch war halt auch OP
Metro, was sonst?
Schon wieder Metro, Alter, please
aber wenigstens mal eine andere Waffe
oh
ja gut, es wird halt auf den Aufgang gerade ausgeschossen
das kann mal vorkommen
da stehen sie immer aufgereiht
ich hatte in einem letzten Video
auch so ein Massive Clip
das letzte Video, wo ich
Battlefield 3 gezeigt habe, wobei
ne, wartet mal, wartet mal
leider, das ist bei mir nicht gut
ausgegangen, passt mal auf hier
das war das Azubi, das Azubi Video
guckt mal hier, da hatte ich auch am Anfang
ein Massive Clip drin
kommt das jetzt hier klar?
der Herr Endpunkt hat den Fokus
ja, ja, Max, passt mal auf, jetzt, jetzt
ne, noch nicht? Moment, Moment
wo kommt der, wo kommt der Clip?
ha, ist nicht da
by the way, hat jemand das Video gesehen hier?
ich hab letztens, äh, vor zwei Tagen oder so
mit der Endpunkt telefoniert
geht's gut?
ah, Big Stonks
ah, hier, jetzt kommt's, jetzt kommt's
passt mal auf, jetzt kommt's
guck mal hier, ich stell's mich um die Ecke
ich stell's mich um die Ecke
er hat das Video gesehen, deswegen hat er sich gemeldet, ja
guck mal, ich stell's um die Ecke
BÄM, auf einmal fünf Gegner vor mir
ich so, ups
leider haben die sich umgedreht
ich konnte sie nicht alle wegsprayen
das wär aber auch geil gewesen
hätte ich die alle wegsprayen können
naja, egal, guck mal weiter
wo sind wir stehen geblieben?
Andy the Lion is pretty insane
he's playing on Metro once again
this time he's placed some C4
waiting for the enemies to push down
on a game of Rush
you can do this pretty much every time you play
if you time it right
yeah, kann man machen
oh, wie sie sich wegsprayen lassen
alter
in your face, Alter
gesprüht und gebetet, er
weiter
das ist ja Wahnsinn, ey, die rennen immer noch rein
deswegen ist übrigens
ich geh nie da runter, ich geh nie runter
ich geh immer in die mittlere
in den mittleren mit dem Waggon
die laufen immer noch durch
ich fass es nicht
ha, ha, ha, lol
kannst du so Döner-App machen, wo du so zeigst
wo günstiger Dönerladen ist
wenn du ne geile API hast
wo man günstigsten Dönerladen
für die Umgebung abfragen kann
mach ich das
Döner-Champ
der Döner-Champ kommt dann
ich mein, wir haben ja schon den Preis-Champ gemacht
den Cool-Champ, den Watt-Champ
der Döner-Champ kommt dann an
da fehlt eigentlich nur noch der Döner-Champ
ich hab jetzt übrigens mit diesem Mist auch auf der Arbeit angefangen
alle Sachen, die ich da jetzt angefangen hab zu basteln
sei es Skripts oder irgendwelche
äh, Programme, die heißen alle irgendwas mit Champ im Namen
diese Videos sind immer geil
Lieferando einfach Preise auslesen
ist nicht so einfach
...
die arme Katze, Alter
da gibt es ultra lustige Videos in der Richtung
ja, das ist auch geil
...
ich kann mir den Scheiß den ganzen Tag angucken, Alter
oh Mann
deswegen kriege ich wahrscheinlich auch so viel von diesen Schwachsinsvideos empfohlen
...
Kann man Corona-News eigentlich ausblenden?
Ich meine, Chat.
Chat, warum sollten wir uns Corona-News durchlesen, wenn doch allgemein bekannt ist, dass es Corona gar nicht gibt?
Das verstehe ich nicht, warum YouTube da News überhaupt dazu anzeigt.
Painz-Chat, ist ja gut, ich gebe zu.
Ich gebe zu, war zu offensichtlich.
Ja, habt ihr recht, ihr habt ja recht.
Guck einfach nur in deine Abo-Box.
Lol, weh.
Ich habe außer meinem Fake-Account mich hier nie eingeloggt.
OMG, Omega-Lull-Wupp.
Mit was für einem Schwachsinn haben wir uns hier dann mal eingeloggt.
Was haben wir sonst noch hier?
Doom on a Commercial Kitchen Appliance.
Ich hoffe, das ist nicht so langweilig.
What the fuck?
Ist das Windows 95?
Ist ja Bleeding Edge-Zeugs drin.
Läuft sogar ziemlich gut.
Leaked.
Ich glaube nicht.
Ich glaube nicht, dass da irgendwas leaked ist.
Das ist irgendein Fake-Account, den wir uns mal für Fake-Sachen im Stream angelegt haben.
Leute, ich habe Hunger.
Ist da Frasier am Start?
Ich glaube, ich hoste jetzt den Frasier und gehe fressen.
Gab es eigentlich schon viele News zu Battlefield 6?
Nicht wirklich.
Nicht wirklich, ne?
Also, eigentlich gar keine News.
Doch, gerade keine, die ich irgendwie hosten kann.
Lass mal kurz, lass mal kurz gucken.
Science and Technology.
Wer ist in Science and Technology am Start?
Auf Twitch?
Der Deutsch spricht?
Können wir da irgendjemanden hosten?
Moment.
Wie macht man jetzt hier nochmal die Filter auf German?
Ich bin da zu dumm für.
Ich kann Twitch nicht bedienen.
Ja, German.
Aha.
Arduino Grill.
Excellent.
Betriebssystem in PHP.
Monk AS.
Also, es gibt ja sicherlich Sachen, die kann man machen, aber die muss man nicht unbedingt machen.
Mömmelmonster TV.
Gibt es?
Gibt es Cat?
Cat?
Gibt es Katzen-Streams?
Oh.
Exzellent.
Was ist das?
Ne.
Ach so, ich dachte, das ist eine Katze, aber es ist nur ein Kissen.
Na gut, dann hoste ich keinen, Leute.
Wir sehen uns.
Ich gehe jetzt was fordern.
Ich habe mega Hunger.
Bis dann.
Vielleicht sehen wir uns heute Abend nochmal.
Mach's gut.
See you.